the latest release in the Twitter files
from Elon Musk and it could not have
been on a more perfect day a Monday
afternoon brilliant because you know
I've been whinging about how they keep
releasing this stuff on Friday and
Saturday well now we got possibly the
biggest release in my opinion as it
pertains to what's going on behind the
scenes at Twitter hard evidence that the
Twitter executive's knew Trump did not
break any rules and you can actually see
the communications between the staff and
the executives as to how to falsely
justify removing a sitting president
from the social media app of course
world leaders leaders around the world
were angry that they did it and said
they said it was a bad precedent even
leftist ones in Europe so seeing this
look we knew I say new quote unquote
because we knew because we're not stupid
but now we have the communications
Vijaya got a personally intervened after
they said Trump broke no rules and said
well
is it coded incitement to violence
perhaps and they went oh oh yeah that's
right that's our justification for
removing the president from Twitter so
we'll talk about that plus Sam bankman
freed has been arrested okay uh finally
I guess and then we have that story of
the mainstream media loves more than the
actual groundbreaking leaks we have Elon
Musk was booed while on stage with Dave
Chappelle all right all right we'll play
ball we'll talk about that before we get
started head over to timcast.com become
a member to help support our work as a
member you'll get access to exclusive
members only segments of this show just
click that join us button over at
timcast.com we're gonna have one for you
tonight at around 11 pm so don't forget
to smash that like button right now
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends if you really do want
to support us if everybody who watched
shared this video on social media we'd
be bigger than the mainstream media
overnight
so again smash that like button joining
us tonight to talk about this and so
much more is Phil Labonte hello uh uh
thank you for having me
um I am Phil Levante I sing for the
metal band All That Remains uh I am Phil
that remains on Twitter and I run my
face a lot
right on well thanks for coming man it's
gonna be fun that was like the the most
concise and and to the point
introduction normally people linger you
know you know I didn't want to take up a
whole bunch of time there's a lot of
things that we're going to talk about we
can go ahead and talk about Luke's
shirts and then we can go ahead and talk
about you and then we can jump right
into it I know how things go around here
guys
can we have a war cry just a random
random war cry
yeah thank you Phil for joining us I
really appreciate that my name is Luke
randowski here we are change.organ today
I'm wearing one of my older shirts that
reads I survived 2020 and all I got was
masks riots a lockdown more surveillance
the great reset and this shirt and you
could get this shirt on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
guys do that this is the main way to
support me and thank you so much for
doing so Ian how are you doing great man
I was just watching Phil's war cry that
was a good one was moving while it was
happening because Tim was getting
focused or something so it's like
shaking yeah it's really intense always
great to hear your voice Phil even
better in person my man thank you sir
thanks for coming dog Kellen tell me
about it that war cry was like a cup of
coffee I'm gonna be honest with you that
that woke me up um hey everyone it's
Kellen I'm back again let's get started
and uh and and Luke did anything
anything happen today that you won't
shut up about no I mean I I don't know I
don't think so no something big it did
happen Elon Musk followed Luke because
he agreed probably I don't know why but
he uh you mentioned you respond wanted
to him about the future of humanity and
he seems to agree with you someone wrote
me a congrats on getting a federal agent
assigned to you and I responded like I
already had one for 15 years I
confronted David Rockefeller and Henry
Kissinger I think I already have one so
maybe now I have two so wish me luck
guys look watching the front door and
he's looking around all excited trying
to find somebody he's holding up his
phone just with like Elon Musk follows
you it's like okay Luke Luke you didn't
you didn't have like you had one person
before now you actually have a desk yes
I probably have a I hope I have a floor
that's my uh that's my uh you know
bucket list
the the agents are watching the show
eating popcorn being like they're gonna
say something you know I'd be like look
I there's I imagine that the things that
come along with having a floor uh of
paying attention to you are bad usually
they're attached to drones I don't think
that I want a floor of the of the FBI
opinion they're going to be assessing
all the memes yeah what does this mean
what is this yeah I'm all set I'm Gonna
Be Alone I want that much attention no
shirts are really good all right let's
jump to this first story we got this one
from timcast.com Twitter files
Executives acknowledged Trump did not
violate terms of service proposed quote
coded incitement to further violence
stipulation it was really amazing when
you read Twitter's Public Announcement
as to why they banned Trump they say
it's all it's all assumptive language
like further incitement and additional
violations will mean and they say all of
that because they never once say Trump
did break the rules but now we have the
internal Communications themselves
take a look at this some dissenters uh
in Twitter albeit one saying maybe
because I'm from China he says I deeply
understand how censorship can destroy
public conversations
but let's uh let's jump right to it you
have this Annika Nava uh navaroli who
says that they assessed Donald Trump's
tweet and found there is no violation of
our policies at this time now that's
interesting because this woman later
went on to testify for the January 6
committee that she was trying to warn
Twitter that they had to do something
about this take a look at this Twitter
employees on the scaled enforcement team
suggest that Trump's tweet may have
violated Twitter's glorification of
violence policy oh that's here we go
there's vijayagare less than 90 minutes
after Twitter employee to determine that
Trump's tweets were not in violation of
the policy Vegeta sorry vijigare
Twitter's head of legal policy and Trust
asked whether it could in fact be coded
incitement to further violence
they knew and get this
when you when you go through these
messages the amazing thing is you can
see them lying and basically they might
as well be saying guys make up a reason
to ban Trump and get it to me it's got
to make sense it's basically what
they're saying on January 6th Trump said
no violence he tweeted out no violence
were the party of Law and Order on
January 8th he said 75 million American
Patriots who voted for me your voices
will be heard and then he tweeted again
I will not be going to the inauguration
they twist themselves into knots to
claim that because he said American
Patriots he was he was referring to
writers on January 6. because he said I
will not be there he was actually saying
you have the go-ahead to attack because
I won't be there therefore I'll be safe
and then Twitter employees said that
Donald Trump is now viewed like the head
of a terrorist organization no different
than Hitler or the Christchurch shooter
therefore he must be banned how insane
of a concept is that that Donald Trump
regardless of how anyone feels about
Donald Trump and the things that he said
the the idea that Donald Trump is as bad
as Hitler yeah
I I can't I can't take that seriously I
cannot I can't I can't imagine how you
sit with someone and say all right you
said that and now other things that come
out of your mouth I have to make believe
that they're serious too
I I can't even I can't I can't it just
it's so ridiculous
i i people are detached from what Hitler
was really like he was like a war
veteran broken brain I think who is was
it surge maybe was telling me he lost a
bunch of his friends in the trench he
went out to run a mission when he came
back they were all dead yeah nerve gas
damage a whole bunch of drugs a whole
bunch of uh methamphetamine yeah yeah
there's a big difference between you
know Donald Trump and his Diet Cokes and
McDonald's uh now again I'm not the
biggest fan of of Donald Trump but but
the man was actively calling for for
peace telling people on Twitter like hey
the you know doing the opposite of what
they accuse him of so so for them to
construde American Patriots as some kind
of coded incitement is absolutely
derangement type thinking that is
nonsensical that is as you said insane
these people are absolutely crazy they
lost their marbles they lost the plot
they don't know what's going on here and
and they will think of any reason just
to punish any kind of political speech
that they don't like because it triggers
them and it activates this kind of fight
or flight instincts in them that scares
the crap out of them it's a ball drop by
administration at Twitter because you
you get as an administrator I know this
firsthand doing it at mines you get the
you face with the decision I have to do
what either what I want to happen or
what is right and often what you want is
not what is right so you have to do
what's right and you don't get what you
want out of it but here's my question
because I generally don't understand
like how is there a difference between
between the two you know in my
perspective
I don't want anything from any of these
people if I was a moderate in these
platforms you know you've got uh the
krakensteins are back on Twitter so
thank god well I mean I gotta be honest
like the return tweet was actually
really funny did you see it well and I
didn't but I know that they're LOL cows
and I want that sweet sweet milk yeah so
uh the Crescent scenes were huge Trump
reply guys they got banned and I I
believe they got banned for false under
false pretenses and then when they came
back I mean they're like they did the
whole thing where you know I think Don
Jr blocked one of them so he was like
free speech in quotes and I'm like oh
these are the kind of guys there but uh
they they uh posted The Ambiguously Gay
Duo from SNL and it said the Crescent
scene brother return of Twitter to hunt
the ghost of Donald Trump I was like
that's actually really good back in the
day that's a good one back in the when
they were before they got banned I
thought that the The Ambiguously Gay Duo
was something that was associated with
them regularly yeah yeah yeah it made a
meme they made a good meme it's perfect
if the world wasn't in such Dire Straits
of starvation and like falling apart
with no electricity and disease and
stuff this would be really funny I would
be loving all this Twitter drama it's so
hilarious because I really love all
these people from all sides you know
it's just enjoyable to watch everybody
go at it if the stakes weren't so hot so
so here's my my view I suppose
they're on the platform they're back
they should have never been taken off
despite the fact that I'm gonna argue
with them you know I don't for me
doing what right is is doing right by
the users by by people and the human
rights is what I would want it's strange
to me but I get it I guess people like
it's strange that as you mentioned it
Ian that there would be someone sitting
there saying I know the right thing to
do would be let this person speak but I
hate them so I'm going to remove them
like that that that's crazy to me I'd
have situations where I was like I agree
with these politics but the right thing
to do is put it in the politics bucket
because it's politics even though I want
it to be on the front page and everyone
to believe what I believe so I'd have to
choose to do what was right when you
need to stretch interpretations and make
up things that aren't there to justify
you shutting down on political voice
maybe you're the bad guy maybe that's
when you should kind of reconsider what
you're doing here but more interestingly
Donald Trump hasn't tweeted yet he's
been back on the platform for for many
days and we talked about this before on
the show and I was like hey there's a
big chance he won't actually be using
the platform why isn't he he has an
opportunity here and uh it looks like
Elon Musk is taking his place when it
comes to everyone especially the
corporate media focusing and attacking
him maybe that's one reason why but he's
still not back on the platform he has an
opportunity to reach so many people to
communicate with so many people he's
still not everybody already does though
I mean he anytime he puts up a truth on
Truth social they make it they make
their way to is Roseanne Barr on on uh
social what I'm saying is anyone anytime
that Donald Trump puts a truth up it
makes the truth makes its way over to
Twitter so it's literally advertising
for such well I just think about the
semantics puts a truth up well I know
it's it's crazy it's hard to it's hard
to articulate these things without
sounding he's not talking to Governors
he's not talking to politicians he's not
he's not talking to celebrities he's not
firing back against the corporate media
like he used to be there used to be
interactions that were extremely
entertaining to watch where he was able
to shine with a lot of his character
some people said that it was his
Achilles heel some people said it was
his greatest strength but it was
something that of course galvanized the
conversation there's there's none of
that right now yeah that but I see what
you're saying you're right that Elon
might be filling the void I'm looking at
his tweets he had a tweet that had 1.2
million likes uh about go Morocco you
know talking about uh football soccer
um he had my pronouns are prosecute
slash fauci which got 1.1 million likes
a million 1.1 million likes he seems to
have taken the role of the the male
strong male that Young Americans or
young humans around Earth are looking
for for inspiration right now it used to
be Donald Trump that's one but the
corporate media and the establishment
need a boogeyman that they go after that
they Galvanize all behind that that make
them responsible for all the wrongs in
the world and that person right now is
Elon Musk yes they're going after him
with anything and everything they can
let me let me address the uh you
mentioning about Donald Trump fighting
back and all that stuff I want to pull
up this tweet from 2012. Trump tweeted
the Coca-Cola company is not happy with
me that's okay I'll still keep drinking
that garbage all right all right all
right guys
take it back right now Phil back I take
it back that's freaking awesome that's
nice Trump was he was he was that that
was his platform it was it was still
fire drinking that garbage
it was it was fire it was yeah take it
back now he just goes on Trump and he's
like the rig Twitty treaty and I'm just
like it's like paragraph with the
paragraph of him complaining about 2020
and it's like come on Donald Trump does
anymore though and I know I'm gonna piss
a lot of Donald Trump fans off all
Donald Trump does is wine anymore he is
just even if he was like
everyone knows that all these bad things
happened and I was it was you know taken
from me and blah blah blah whatever he
you know whatever his line is even if he
said all that stuff and then said but
from here on out we're gonna focus on
the future and yada yada yada he'd be in
a he'd be much more
he'd attract more voters people are so
tired of listening to him complaining
because even people that were
sympathetic to his his takes before
people like myself and like you know
Luke and and people that at the very I
was more critical of them well what I
mean was were sympathetic to the idea
that the the there is a problem in
Washington sympathetic to the idea that
there is an establishment that needs
someone pushing back against him against
it
people that were sympathetic to that
idea are tired of poor me they're just
over it yeah and I think that uh I think
they're they're right to be tired of it
because I I just if his thing is just
poor me then he's not gonna get anything
done he's not gonna fix anything he's
not gonna be anything better since uh
Trump was reinstated I can pull this
tweet up the actual tweet not an image
of it where he said federal judge throws
that stormy Daniel lawsuit great now I
can go after horse face and her third
rate lawyer in the great state of Texas
she will confirm the letter she signed
she knows nothing about me a total Khan
he was the president
why are you calling her a horse face you
paid for that a lot of money too dumb
man he paid top dollar
that wasn't cheap well you know
he likes horsey women you don't like why
did you purchase that product like
seriously as much as I can be like
you know I've been critical of Trump's I
guess decorum in the past like you know
he can be better people kept saying this
is exactly why they liked him
because he would just he just say what
he felt like saying you know he just say
it I mean he was ridiculous and that was
that was the funny thing about him but
that that was also the thing that made
people hate him the most and that was
the thing that that did align the
establishment against him I think saying
what you think can be is a is a valuable
ability but if what you think is evil
horrible dirty things then saying what
you think is going to be bad if it's
good things then saying what you think
is going to be good I think you're right
but I think delivery has a lot to do
with it because there are plenty of
people saying plenty terrible things in
a very gentle way nowadays and it's
getting right by people well let's be
honest Donald Trump was funny he was
humorous and he made us laugh about very
serious issues some people he would he
would push back on when they needed to
be pushed back done but when it came to
uh establishment Powers he laughed at
them and that that has had it has its
own presence that is missing so I want
to pull out this tweet we were just
talking about how Elon said my pronouns
are prosecute slash fouchy and in a lot
of ways elon's filling that void that
Trump filled I gotta Wonder
did Elon look at what made Twitter big
saw that it was Trump and then said If
I'm going to fix this platform we need a
new trump-like figure so Twitter was
actually dying then Donald Trump starts
running for president starts tweeting up
a storm and all of a sudden Twitter just
takes off
then when Trump is out Twitter starts
going down Elon comes in and now he's
doing very similar things tweeting
things that rile people up posting memes
responding to people he is very much
filled that void on Twitter of what
Trump was so we have this interaction
that went viral over the weekend
Elon Musk said my pronouns are prosecute
slash fauci and Scott Kelly the
astronaut says Elon please don't Mock
and promote hate towards already
marginalized and at risk of violence
members of the lgbtq plus Community they
are real people with real feelings
furthermore Dr fauci is a dedicated
public servant whose sole motivation was
saving lives and Elon said I strongly
disagree forcing your pronouns upon
others when they didn't ask and
implicitly ostracizing those who don't
is neither good nor kind to anyone as
for fauci he lied to Congress and funded
gain of function research that killed
millions of people not awesome in my
opinion
concise holy smokes he got the joke in
there and the pushback of the narrative
yeah and so fauci was working with what
Eco Health Alliance and uh what's that
Peter Peter dashik and they were sending
money was it what um fauci's company
fauci's government it was like his
National Institute Donald Trump approved
chain of function work and as soon as he
did Dr fauci in his office authorized it
with Echo Health Alliance and Peter
dazak who's alleged to be uh working
with the CIA to do it in Wuhan China
specifically at the level three
laboratory of virology there where they
worked on uh activated weaponized uh
coronavirus that's all confirmed yes
okay so then when he went under Congress
to testify Anthony fauci uh he testified
and said we didn't do gain a function he
lied he lied he lied yeah but but he was
redefining the word he was trying to use
semantics hold on he outright lied like
it wasn't even that he just straight up
lied and then Rand Paul actually pulled
up the study where he's like it
literally says here gain a function it's
one thing if the study said we're doing
research with viruses to do X Y and Z
it's another thing when the study
literally says gain of function research
and then in fact she's like no no yeah
Barack Obama specifically banned it and
and Dr fauci couldn't do it and and the
government couldn't do it under Barack
Obama because Barack Obama said there's
too many inherent risks towards making a
virus as lethal as possible but the
point I wanted to get to with this is
how Elon Musk has become a more
articulate Trump on Twitter you know
what I mean
yeah he's not American so there's no
fear of him running for president so I
don't think the Deep state is too
concerned he is an American but he can't
be the president he's not a naturalized
citizen he's a citizen but he wasn't
born he wasn't born in the United States
so he's not available to run for
president so I think that the
establishment may not be nearly as
concerned about Elon as they are about
Donald Trump I don't know he started
releasing their Communications yeah and
Elon did more when it comes to the
Battle of free speech than any
Republican in the recent recent decade
ever ever did anything I've got it for
free speech what do you say go ahead go
ahead well I'm gonna I'm at a Crossroads
kind of where I'm like what do we do do
we side with the liberal economic order
or do we decide with the bricks the
Chinese economic order neither or is
there a third opt there's another option
just a decentralized world yeah you know
don't have to decide what a superpower
all the time being you know you don't
have to side with an Overlord you don't
need an overlordian you don't need
agreement
you don't need people telling
and you could fill them
I'm real romantic I'm I'm really
romantic for anarchism like I I don't
I'm not the guy that's like I think that
anarchism is the right solution for
every but we should be striving towards
it but it is it is a good goal to have
exactly voluntary interactions and all
interact in all human interactions is a
good goal to have exactly we should
always strive for that United the United
States is people say the United States
is gonna no no the United States are
doing things because it's a bunch of
State it's not an entity it's not it's a
bunch of states that have opted to work
federal government is an entity that is
independent and separate from the city
states so to say the United States are
is no longer accurate because you're
talking about what the United States
federal government one entity is doing I
see the largest Hawaii Luke likes Ian
because Ian gives him a layup
that's why I'm here baby I'm playing
support yeah regeneration healing that's
what I'm doing he ends like but which
which Overlord should I pick and then
Luke does the the more you know actually
big questions I've been so concerned
about the liberal economic order since
Zeitgeist since 2005 and six and I'm
like oh the buildings came down in a
free fall near Free Fall what the hell
so they were like almost my enemy in my
mind I'm like how do we but now I'm
seeing the Chinese there's more than one
economic order well so you want to get a
little weird think about this the the
the the and this is something that I've
been thinking about that I think Elon
Musk is doing he's looking at Twitter
starlink uh SpaceX it's all one thing
for him
as much as they are different businesses
essentially he is laying the groundwork
with those companies
to make interplanetary life possible
and that's they all will they all have a
certain Synergy together if you can get
big heavy stuff off of the planet and
get to Mars and you can colonize Mars
and you then you could put starlink you
would want to put starlink around that
planet as well because you would want to
be able to communicate he all of this
stuff works together
if you're thinking how do we make human
beings interplanetary or multi-planetary
is Mars and then from there on I don't I
don't think I think Twitter and starlink
are rudiment I'll stop people are saying
that Twitter would be a really great way
to communicate if you're uh
interplanetary because they're short
burst messages you can say a thing and
then after a few minutes it lands
everybody sees it it lasts forever so
it's you know effective for
interplanetary communication I disagree
I think entangle uh quantum entanglement
is how we're going to do interplanetary
communication or sympathetic vibration
using crystalline uh communication like
you vibrate one crystal in Earth's
atmosphere and then the Crystal and
Mars's atmosphere starts to vibrate to
it's different than entanglement but
similar but all that's none of that none
of those things have the technology now
elon's taking existing technology and
pushing it as far as it can go seeing
how much we have and really kind of TR
it's really testing where is the line
that the things that we have uh can
perform a a task and what needs to be
innovated to perform tasks that need to
be done to allow for internet
Interstellar travel I like Elon because
he's like take what we have and start he
went he's at least using Rockets to get
us out there it's not cost efficient we
need an elevator we need space elevators
and this graphene material looks like
it'll be the tether I knew graphene was
coming yeah super strong tether material
you can send stuff up into orbit all day
you know like 60 different elevators
going up and down all day at this one
base station in Mexico or something
everyone drink uh he said it also I
found it very interesting to see him
tweet after this Elon Musk specifically
saying quote the branch covidians are
upset specifically talking about the The
covid Cult of people who wanted
lockdowns who wanted restrictions who
wanted to mask everyone who wanted a
procedure to be forced onto everyone
they're still pushing for it and those
people represent a lot of big interest
especially when it comes to Big Pharma
especially when it comes to the
corporate media and the government
working for a big Pharma that is
essentially their marketing arm right
now so seeing him push back against this
he also had a meeting with the Stanford
Professor that was censored for trying
to stop the lockdowns he also is talking
about starting a new science board on
Twitter that's going to be able to judge
information and actually call it out for
for being either honest or dishonest so
he's pushing back against a lot of
powerful people and when you truly to
look do look at what he's been doing
especially with the people that he has
freed especially with the people that he
is allowed to still have a voice on a
platform that is relevant more than ever
uh this is a progression towards free
speech and and I think it's it's the
right road to be on and if there if he's
unraveling all of this on Twitter just
imagine what's happening at alphabet
what's happening at Tick Tock what's
happening on Reddit what's happening on
Facebook on Instagram you can only
imagine as of course these organizations
all work in unison when it comes to
stifling descent Banning people and
censoring ideas that they don't like
which they work in tandem with Elon just
tweeted follow and a rabbit emoji
yeah follow the one on the rabbit hole
is that a white rabbit so he's been
talking to yeah email Chong says
although all the way down the rabbit
hole Yeah
I wonder what he's got coming next you
know what you're saying well he's also I
gotta I gotta say one thing in regards
to this
the Twitter files have shown in order to
censor someone with more than 10 000
followers and and people who are high
profile needed special teams to
intervene this means that the word
groomer the Banning of James Lindsay
were direct manual intervention this
means that they have conversations about
James Lindsay and why they banned them
and when they suspended my account for
having said groomer about an adult man
who is showing sexual images to children
they locked my account and I have 1.4
million followers that means I would I
would I'd be willing to bet it was Joel
Roth himself
saying okay apply a ban on his channel
until he deletes it you know how long
until you got that one back instant
instant it's it's sad if you want to use
Twitter delete this tweet and I was like
I gotta be honest because I I don't
think there's any moral victory in in
keeping a tweet up that just has a
sentence from like three months ago so I
said sure whatever deleted it then
posted about it I thought posting about
it was more effective yeah but I want to
see the communications about their
justifications for this because the
other big story here is that
Joel Roth who was the the like top guy
of their moderation was actively posting
about children consenting and other
creepy things like this that people have
basically pointed to saying the dude was
obsessed with gay porn he was posting
nonsense about it he had he had a dummy
account a sock puppet where he would
post lewd things apparently and his Elon
Musk called him out saying his his was
it his PhD thesis was arguing for like
minors to have access to adult sex apps
the PHD thesis thing I read some stuff
about it and the thing that I read
yeah I don't think that he was arguing
for underage people to be encouraged to
use those things the way that
people are saying that he was arguing he
was saying look kids get into Apps kids
get porn kids get these things so trying
to say that they trying to just keep
them off doesn't work now I don't think
he's right and I disagree with the point
that he was trying to make but I don't
think that in his PhD thesis he was
intending to say that we should but here
here's what was this topic it was he he
did like uh uh a PhD thesis on the use
of Grindr and stuff like that
I'm not going to come out and say that
the dude actively said children should
be hooking up with adults on these apps
the issue is that he said kids are
already on these apps therefore we need
to consider that there needs to be
something for them to use blah blah blah
and I'm like yeah that's called that's
the erosion
that's how we get from if if you went
back in time 14 years and said if you
know this this this this bill passes or
if gay marriage is legalized they're
going to be teaching kids how to have
gay sex in schools they'd laugh at you I
mean that was a common talking point now
project Veritas releases a video showing
the dean in a Chicago school was at
Francis W Parker talking about how he
was there as he brought someone into
hand around adult toys and that's a
private school right private school and
when I talk to these leftists they're
like well they're just teaching sex ed
but you know queer sex head and I'm like
and there it is they said it wouldn't
happen of course it happened if YOLO
Roth is going to come out and say look
they're already on these apps this he's
basically saying the solution isn't to
enforce the policies saying miners
shouldn't be using adult hookup apps
he's saying well you know they're
already there so uh and this is the
issue here and I really want to bring
this up because you add that to the fact
that when he was running things at
Twitter which essentially he was he was
calling all the shots he was deciding
who was going to be banned and not
banned there was children that came to
the company and said hey yes my photos
were uploaded when I was a child of me
uh committing uh you know adult actions
please take it off Twitter said no it
doesn't violate our policy he kept it on
the platform as it was on their servers
as they were meeting with the FBI weekly
you're supposed to report those things
to the FBI immediately they were sitting
and chatting with the FBI almost once a
week if not even more and you add this
to the fact of if you want to go down
the rabbit hole we can uh and Jack
pesobic actually kind of pointed at this
and hinted at this too there is a
possibility that the feds caught
somebody let's just say someone like
yoel in in a precarious situation or on
a website and potentially said hey we
have you on this particular charge you
have to act on our beheads unless we
expose you and making you go to jail
that's one possibility that could be
happening here I'm not saying that
there's actual proof here but with the
way that the FBI has been operating
within the United States it's fair to
speculate that this is a major
possibility here okay there is literally
nothing that I would put past the FBI I
have absolutely zero confidence in the
FBI as an organization uh and I think
it's corrupt as as it gets that being
said I don don't know that there is any
kind of evidence that makes me think
that they have something on Joel that
would make uol
dis ignore child porno what about
Jeffrey Jeffrey Epstein but he was
I'm not saying that he wasn't I'm saying
no I don't know that I don't know the
FBI has anything on so my question is
then why why were they ignoring it I
just think ul's kind of a bad person
but there but there was more than just
him there's a bunch of people that they
knew it was happening and the outright
were like nah uh I I can't even
speculate I can't even I gotta I gotta
wrap my head around how you justify
leaving that kind of stuff up without
taking like and not taking it maybe it
was like I can't like you complained or
or person a complained but they couldn't
confirm that it was actually person a no
families and children came to them and
said hey this is me this is on my
platform like yeah this is fine this is
totally cool and and when we look at
when we look at the FBI this this is not
something that's uncommon this is
something that is common children and
and other people were coming to them in
the 90s saying hey there's this guy with
the Private Island who's doing these
things to us they ignored them for over
30. we know the FBI ignored uh the uh
Simone bile uh I think is that that are
named the Olympic Athlete the Simone
biles was her name yeah yeah and there
was there was other people that and that
other Gym trainer yeah they went to the
FBI and the FBI didn't do anything
so yeah I like I said I my faith in the
FBI is almost not well non-existent I
have I have no use for it and I'm you
know I'm the guy that wants to get rid
of
cabinet level bureaucracies abolish
cabinet level bureaucracies get rid of
them a lot of them so I wanted to get
that out I don't think uh he needs dirt
on yoel to get him to cooperate I think
FBI probably reached out and he went
whoa yeah cool the FBI yeah I think he
was like sick let's do this the messages
yeah in the in the Twitter files where
he's like definitely not meeting with
the FBI right now about Trump there was
there was no need to encourage anyone at
Twitter to get them to to behave in a
hostile manner manner towards Donald
Trump or anyone else that they possibly
would conceive of as a deplorable I have
one big regret from that interview I did
with Joe Rogan and it's that it did not
occur to me to ask Vijaya and Jack if
they had been in communication with the
government at all and that was so I look
back on that so stupid because it should
have been question number one okay
you're you're Banning people is the
government in any way involved in
directing you or advising you or
requesting you take anybody down didn't
even occur to me to ask that because we
weren't you know it's it's the context
the time at the time the big question
was Private companies and what they were
doing but uh now I look back like just
just to get out of the way like just as
a formality government are they involved
in any way well they probably would have
lied you know that would have been good
though get them on on tape lying or uh
or telling the truth on that one I think
you know in regard to Joel before we get
too far away from this uh dissertation
that he did this PhD thesis I think it's
called Gay data is the name of it um I
think what he was indicating is not he's
saying like you were mentioning Tim
earlier that we have Grindr and uh kids
are getting on Grindr and that's a
problem how do we solve it I think what
he was suggesting is that we have an app
for miners like a grinder for miners or
a Tinder for miners but where that falls
short is like how the hell can you stop
adults from getting in there I mean
that's only marginally horrifying yeah
that sounded absolutely right uh I mean
that's like I mean contemplating Tinder
for children yes no yeah but also but
but also I'm pretty sure he talks about
how Grindr isn't actually a dating app
it's a hookup app how these guys aren't
meeting to find love they're geolocating
each other for hookups that's what I was
reading about I don't want to disparage
any of these guys who may be trying to
find love I don't know I don't I don't I
I don't know about you know
I don't know I I don't know how it works
but I the idea of children being on
Tinder I like I've I've got a Tinder
account and it's a mess out there it is
it is craziness and and so no right this
is this is the point recommending but
they're already using these apps because
I want to meet people right we should
make apps for them no no no no that's
how they move the line they keep moving
the line they're like well kids are
gonna yeah kids are gonna date when a
kid's in high school he hangs out as
high school kids he hangs out his
classmates and the kids the the chick
from Seventh Peters got Jim and he's got
home a room whatever they meet they
don't go on dating apps and then just
start swiping right on random people in
their neighborhood it's bad enough
adults do it yeah that there is no I
can't I can't come up with justification
to give children that's that's the
erosion of that you can look I'm not
giving this guy yo all the benefit of
the doubt at all because the Dude
literally was the head of this stuff
when exploitation was on Twitter and
they weren't taking it down so my
assumption is he must enjoy it so I'm
not going to give him benefit of the
doubt but I I I look at what's what's
going on and you get people who say
something like oh a drag show isn't
sexualized and I'm like they literally
take their clothes off do the splits
drop low twerk in front of people like
it is it is to cut to say that a drag
show is not sexualized I again that's
another thing where it's like all right
well I can't I can't seriously engage in
a conversation with you because we
you're not gonna come from a a place of
honesty like but then there's no there's
there's no moving forward with solving
these issues it's such a black pill such
a black pill take and if you look at
well hold on like look I got because no
moving forward like if you're actually
saying no moving forward no more head
forward is real bad have you had a
conversation when they left us about
this stuff and see them on Twitter all
the time
I've got they're insane there are
friends of mine that we've had calm
conversations there's a friend of mine
on Facebook people need to understand
this because the leftists refused to
acknowledge it okay Luke and I were both
Wall Street three thousand people follow
me they're all leftist occupy people
when the death threats came in I get a
message from a few people they're on the
left and they're like look man I know we
disagree I disagree with the things
you've said but this is wrong we
obviously don't want this say regular
people don't want it these are the kind
of messages I get I then ask them I'm
like here's the video from Project
veritas this teacher was giving these
things to kids and the response from
them is this is acceptable and fine
because it's sex ed for kids on queer
issues and I'm like you see that's it
right there
look if you go
if if you want to justify going to like
six sixth graders 12 year olds and being
like here is anatomy and biology design
and you don't explain to them how to do
anything you just say like you know
here's like what what happened with me
when I was in grade school is they
brought the boys in one room all the
girls another room he said here's the
anatomy here's how it works here's sex
ed and that was it what they're doing
now is under the guise of LGBT plus
curriculum handing children butt plugs
and and other adult toys and explaining
spitting and lubing okay that is well
beyond sex ed that is something
different they're not explaining to them
how to reproduce or how the organs work
is sex and sex ed used to mean yes sex
ed used to be anatomy and and Technical
uh understanding of of the function and
operation as opposed to now it seems
like these classes are more about
classes and the dangers and about well I
I remember they told you hey you could
get these diseases you could get
pregnant this way there wasn't a
conversation and and like a step-by-step
program on how to have butt sex right I
don't remember that in high school but
the realism is that the sex that is
happening on the internet on porn
websites whether we wanted to or not any
kid that wants to find it it is which is
readily available which is free and it's
out there which should make people
question why is it so readily available
why is it so why is there so much out
there why is this so free I want to take
it I want to take you down a bigger
level I want to say one thing to that
even even if you're right that doesn't
mean that the state is in a position to
say well your kids probably have cell
phones or their friends have cell phones
that can access pornography on the
internet so because of that we're just
going to go ahead and step on in here
and insert ourselves into this aspect of
your child's life they don't have any
right to do that just because there's
pornography on the internet and to make
that lead like that's that's not a
logical leap that says oh because
there's porn then the state must do this
thing that's that's that is not an
argument for it in my opinion at all
right parents need to make sure their
kids aren't going on these websites they
don't have phones but this is a problem
but more fatherless homes with more
parents not being able to be there for
their children it's less for a lot of
these devices to raise them and if you
look at the devices that that a lot of
the children surround themselves with
whether it's Instagram or Tick Tock
what's on those platforms what is
suggested to you what is on the explore
options for a lot of these uh apps and
applications what is is it it's it's
it's people shaking their asses it it
it's it's a big fat booty hoes the
thumbnails on Instagram it's like always
some kind of subject suggestive thing I
think it was Alex Stein I think it was
him you pull up Instagram and there was
a video of like a woman on her knees
sticking her tongue out and it was like
then when you play the video it was her
like kneeling down and tying his shoe or
something yeah so to take it to another
level right so we know the FBI plays a
key critical role on big Tech social
media platforms uh you know deciding who
stays deciding what gets played what
gets talked about what gets uh you know
trending in the algorithm I would even
go as far as to say their involvement
revolves around all those issues uh
especially when it came to the Banning
of people uh what all these companies
working in unison so I think that it
even goes even further with them
dictating a lot of this content and
providing a lot of this over
sexualization of children which is
essentially destroying people's uh uh
childhoods and robbing them of their
innocence but also creating a situation
where they're less likely to to have
families in the future essentially
destroying a strong family unit
essentially making individuals that are
more easily to be conquered and more
easily to be enslaved with this larger
social engineering which is happening on
all these apps I heard in um as a
pushback to the people that are
complaining about drag shows a lot of
people are then you might say the left
people on the left the counter is like
well what about beauty pageants what
about seven-year-olds with makeup I
think so too yeah that red makeup and
lipstick is supposed to simulate a woman
that's being is ready to give like
absolutely Jordan Peterson talked about
this extensively and he made a lot of
good references and points especially
when it came to a lot of the makeup that
is suggestive of of procreation let's
just be honest here let's just be ready
with each other so so putting that on
small children putting them in heels is
something that that again should be
pushed back on even if it's those beauty
pageants absolutely push push back on
them immediately because they're just
strange I never I never understood why
they're doing this and it it's just as
bad we've moved on so fast from this is
not happening this is is not happening
to this is happening so what it's okay
yeah that's the main it's not happening
okay it's not happening but if it was
then it would be fine uh now it's
happening it's a good thing
so on and so forth is it because the
kids that were 15 five six years ago
were getting watching porn they think
okay I guess it's normal to see this
stuff now they're 22 or whatever the
ages are and they're making decisions
and they're like yo I was exposed to it
I'm 13. I'm fine so maybe but are you
wrong about everyone you're not fine
you're a pigsty I'm sure of it we've got
issues we got breaking news uh this from
the post-millennial Twitter has
disbanded its Infamous trust and Safety
Council who's uh as Twitter moves into a
new phase we are reevaluating how best
to bring external insights into our
product and policy development work as a
part of this process we have decided
that the trust and Safety Council is not
the best structure to do this
whoa there you go let's see what to be
fair it wasn't very trustworthy and it
didn't keep a lot of people safe yeah
double speak they didn't do any of that
it just banned political speech that's
exactly what it did also it's very
curious to see a lot of these members of
of the the trust and Safety Council kind
of publicly resign after Elon Musk
specifically said that he's going to be
going after child exploitation and adult
content on their website a little
curious about how that happened do you
think that they were asked to keep it on
as like Honeypot stuff
there is some speculation but it's all
speculation but the daily wire also
reported that there was uh allegedly 10
million views of child adult content
material that was watched on the old
Twitter 10 million views that's a lot of
views but what's this is confusing this
is with the daily wires there's a big
difference between a nine-year-old
that's you know some horrible thing is
happening in a 17 year old there's a big
difference in some states 16 is the age
of consent yeah but because of the fact
that we because of the fact that you
can't make a law that is arbitrary you
have to have a dividing you know you
have to have some point where it says
okay this is where we make the decision
uh you you can't have laws that are
arbitrary like that so you have to say
someplace in 18 is as good a place of
any and I think that the argument for
the argument should only be going for
older just because of the way that the
brain develops you know I think that
it's I would I would people that say oh
we should uh we should make sure that
the age to drink and and buy a gun and
to vote and all that stuff is is you
know the same I don't see why they think
it should be made younger that just
doesn't make any sense to me at all you
know well they've been trying to get
everything they want they want the
voting age to be 16. Democrats because
low information voters is how they win
then you get 16 year olds you get
Universal mail-in ballots and then there
you go so what was that well they
eliminated the trust and Safety Council
they say our work is to make Twitter a
safe informative Place uh will be moving
faster and more aggressively than ever
before and we will continue oh say we
will be moving faster and we will
continue to welcome your ideas going
forward about how to achieve this goal
we'll also continue to explore
opportunities to provide focused and
timely input into our work whether
through bilateral or small group
meetings I don't think that there's a
whole lot of uh argument about the fact
that Twitter is far more responsive now
to most people's inquiries than they
ever were before Elon Musk yeah you know
it's not on the platform it's not like
you could tweet at Jack and expect Jack
to do anything or you could tweet at uh
you know parag and expect Prague to do
anything they would just ignore you yeah
he's responding and even explaining a
lot of his unpopular actions like like
not allowing Alex Jones on the platform
he at least gave an explanation we
didn't like it it wasn't a good
explanation but would we get that ever
with Google no what YouTube
yeah I love when the CEO is involved but
uh at the same time I'm concerned about
centralized systems because we were
saying earlier it's cool that Tesla and
SpaceX and Twitter are coming together
to form this Uber mind of communications
and travel but if the FBI hacks into it
if some foreign government hacks into it
if someone buys the companies away from
Elon and then wants to just own Humanity
so we gotta decentralize these systems
these software codes get it out of any
individual's hands as fast as possible
because I do not like one guy making the
decision of who I got to stay and who
has to go I gotta push back on that
because
Elon Musk as the one guy
that owns Tesla and starlink and and
Twitter and stuff that's fine because
the option is government which is run by
bureaucracies and is not responsive and
and all the problems that we had with
with Twitter you get from government
because there's nameless faceless
bureaucrats that are that that that
literally comprise the entrenched
bureaucracy or the Deep State you you
either get
so Sargon avocad Carl Benjamin has been
talking about this idea which I forget
the the the way that he articulates it
but it's essentially where one guy is in
the right place at the right time and is
the right person to do something and
it's it's kind of like a convergence of
this the conditions and the person and
without the person it doesn't happen and
Elon Musk is kind of the person that has
found himself in the position to do the
things that he's doing it's not just
that
um it's not like if it wasn't for the
fact that it's Elon Musk doing it it
wouldn't happen it's not like it's it's
replaceable it's not like anyone could
be there doing it
um so the the idea of breaking it up and
having other people handle it if you
break it up and have other people
handling it there's no guarantee that it
gets done because there's not one person
with the vision and the drive to push to
make this thing happen and sometimes it
comes down to one individual pushing
with the drive and everyone coalescing
around him or people coalescing around
that idea but it's that one person
pushing that really kind of becomes the
Catalyst and we could argue that uh
Twitter is just acting as an arm of the
government with the FBI getting getting
involved and manipulating the public
perception on things with uh cyber
command operations psyops Etc it's just
essentially a function of government
I mean I'm sympathetic to to the the
intent behind what you're saying which
is you want to make sure that an
individual doesn't become corrupt and
derail uh progress towards a certain
goal but I think that having
the option between the right person
pushing for an idea or for a result
versus a bureaucracy trying to come up
with a result I feel like the right
person is the better option not to say
that every individual is the right
person just because you have a person in
a position that's you know has Authority
doesn't mean that that person's gonna
get it done because Charisma and the
ability to work with people and so many
other things go into it that's why it
has to be the right person but I think
that the right person is better than a
bureaucracy the two people I think of in
this example would be Julius Caesar and
George Washington both of them
ultimately ultimate military power
behind one man Washington it was a group
of thinkers that said hey George you're
going to take this for now yeah George
was able to let it go yeah and we need
people like that I think because Caesar
was not I think that that's that's I
think you're right I think that that is
a A very wise take because it is it does
the matter of the person and you're
right because Washington is the guy that
said I have to get I want to give this
power back and I think you're right yeah
yeah it could have either been stolen
from him he held onto it someone could
have assassinated him and become the
next king or um you know any God number
of god-awful things could happen if he
tried to hold on to the power I
understand what you're saying that one
guy can move quickly you can get a lot
done authoritarian regimes including
corporations move quickly because
there's one guy making the decision a
girl but the danger of that for the
social Public Square oh I don't like I
don't see that wait until you Elon
though because someone tweeted at him
and said hey I hope SpaceX and Tesla are
running well with how much time you
spend on Twitter he's like actually the
teams are in place are really good at
what they do so he's already kind of
passing the torch down he kind of just
oversees and puts his name on the
companies yeah plus he's got to post
spicy memes way more important than
Rockets all right so I mean Morocco you
know so that's got to milk the law cows
the meme of the digging up Twitter
secrets in the grave you saw that you
posted that no that was pretty good look
every segment we've had so far has been
about Elon he's just the main character
at this point I guess isn't he uh
unfortunately he's the guy that's
especially considering it's the holidays
he's the guy that's driving the national
conversation and thankfully things have
kind of chilled out in the Ukrainian war
and I say thankfully because that means
fewer people are dying every day when
there's less fighting and that to me is
good
um you know and so I guess that Elon
Musk is the thing to talk about it
didn't chill out it just kind of
literally stopped because of the winter
yeah some of the fighting but they're
still using drone Fair which is
absolutely crazy I just gotta give a
shout out to the latest episode of Rick
and Morty I don't know I don't know if
you guys watch it but there's the
president's in it and he makes a joke
where something happens and he goes well
we'll just blame it on the Saudis they
do this kind of thing they've done this
kind of thing they did do this thing it
was just so well done I was like that's
exactly exactly what happens they did
they did do this thing I wouldn't mind
seeing a meme of Elon in a graveyard
cross-legged meditating and all the
spirits of the ghosts are coming out of
the graves of all this Twitter you heard
anything but I think it's her to say he
is the new Mass formation psychosis
Target he's the one that the corporate
media is is
centralizing their attacks against
they're they're attacking them more than
they are actually covering the
corruption that was at Twitter that was
at the FBI which is very telling they're
trying to make Yol some kind of victim
here they're trying to make Dr fauci
some kind of victim here these are not
actual victims here yoel Roth literally
tweeted about how high school teachers
calling for them to have meaningful
consent with their teachers like
how do you even ask if they could the
answer just no yes so instead of asking
you say they can't why wouldn't you be
even asking that specific question I I
agree
but you see hold on you see the game is
playing a regular person doesn't ask
they just say a child can't consent to
be with their teacher yeah he goes but
can they no are the like literally the
only reason that I'm that I'm that I say
that is so that way like tomorrow or in
a couple days when someone's like oh
blah blah blah like I can say no like I
said
you know I said the actual thing right
and then I can be like you know that's
why the hell does he say it that's an
example of doing what's right versus
doing what you want yeah like sometimes
you just gotta acknowledge the
objectivity of these Psychopaths yeah or
acknowledge the fact that he's dead that
he's he might be playing word games or
whatever and you know it might be just
the way that he's articulating stuff
let's let's talk about this next story
here um the headline from CNBC is Elon
Musk is the most famous guy in the world
he's dominated every story he's the main
character it's all we can talk about no
one can talk about anything else anyway
the actual headline is Elon Musk booed
by crowd after Dave Chappelle brings him
on stage at comedy gig I okay he was
booed he said it wasn't that many people
I don't think it was you know some
people are saying he was mercilessly
booed off stage I think the bigger story
is you know Elon Musk figured out how to
make himself famous and that's that
that's that's for damn sure he figured
out how to make himself the richest guy
on the planet and then he was like no
let's be the most famous guy on the
planet and that's what's happening Dave
Chappelle what Dave Chappelle Braven
bring him out for Chapel really joked
you can't boom because he bought me a
jet pack for Christmas or something like
that is that how is that how Elon got on
stage with Dave Chappelle maybe he let
him on as the richest man on earth and
everyone booed I think maybe because of
that because they're you know envy and
anger but also I don't think he's the
richest man on earth I think maybe on
the boat well on the books oh yeah I'm
talking like yeah Putin you got Saudi
princes that are worth trillion I mean
Clinton Global initiative yeah Bill
Gates is an article that said Evelyn
Roth's child was worth 240 trillion
dollars in 19 2011. I read that article
yeah well the real richest people will
never be known to the general public
because they keep their wealth secret
they don't they don't want to be on the
Forbes list they don't want to be known
to everyone and they have a lot of
assets and resources and have they have
more convincing ways of hiding their
money in their Assets in other ways that
people can't track down to actually see
where they link from there's a reason
journalists that broke the Panama story
were uh essentially assassinated and
exterminated so um and that was just one
small banking institution imagine all
the International Global institutions
where the big powerful people hide all
the king of England I'm sure so go to
the Panama papers are you familiar with
them I'm familiar with them I did I kind
of thought that they came out in like
nothing like people were like oh yeah
they you know kind of like what
Chappelle said oh you know all the stuff
that you think they're doing in that
house they're doing and everyone's like
oh well I guess that they just do it and
then everyone just went back to doing
whatever radio silence yeah not the
Panama papers two weeks it like went
back underground you said people got
killed that exposed it yeah the
journalist how many people do you are
you familiar I knew nothing about that
yeah that's that's pretty Talent so I
mean who Global oligarchy run in bank
accounts out of Panama basically
tax-free I think is the idea
well the real people will money hide
their money right so and they never brag
about it they never highlight it they
never show it to everyone they never try
to show off they never try to be in the
headlines
um and there's a lot of those families
out there that that we have no idea
about which which I think is is
important it's important to note here
but Dave Chappelle also made a very
interesting comment uh trying to joke
about the situation saying that it was
only people in the poor section that
were booing him and then Elon Musk kind
of responded saying that he's uh Rich uh
and then said that famous slogan by Dave
Chappelle which he did on his show
saying you know female dog which kind of
came off a little a little weird family
friendly yeah well now apparently that
someone asked Chris Rock to say it and
then someone told musk to say it or
something the funny thing about this is
there's a conspiracy theory now on the
left where they're like Elon is deleting
the video because it shows him being
booed and it's like yo it's everywhere
Twitter is deleting the video because
it's a dmca violation you can't film
comedy specials at events it's like
being in a movie theater and filming you
can't you can't do it that's why they're
deleting it you don't hear you never
hear or unless there's something going
on like that little thing like you don't
see comedy events you'll see like clips
of concerts and stuff like that and you
know bands playing songs but it's not
like you see the jokes from uh it's
always the Netflix specials at the end
when they've already come up with the
they've gone out and toured and selected
the best jokes and put them together so
that way they can shoot the comedy
special the clips you see are the comedy
special of their best jokes yeah with
some comedy specials you have to leave
your phone at the door you don't even
let them you don't they don't even allow
you to come in there with your phones
yeah
that's like I get it man but it's stupid
because bring two phones like you if you
want to do what you can and all that
really happens that is
people can't access their phone to call
9-1-1 an emergency so it's kind of like
I think it's kind of dumb do you like
try and limit the crowd at All That
Remains concerts never no uh we're we've
always been a very uh well we've always
been one of the Bands that's like we
want people to experience the show the
way that they want to there's a lot of
artists that are like oh you know put
your phone down and be present it is not
in any way going to affect my show if
you hold your phone up because if you
watch people that are filming they are
almost almost never filming or never
watching what they're filming they're
holding it up and they're looking at at
least me if I go in front of them and
they're they're holding up their phone
they're not looking at their phone they
look at me because I'll put my hand out
or something and and so it becomes an
interaction and you know why people film
most of these shows at least my opinion
of it is it's not to share it's a that
they can remember it yeah and so they
can pop their phone and be like that was
awesome and I remember being there but a
lot of people had this idea that people
go to shows halt their phones and
there's like a joke where it's what are
you gonna do no one can see it you're
gonna share that video No One's Gonna
even no it's for the people it's for the
people who are there to never forget it
they're taking a piece of the show with
them or fireworks it'd be interesting if
we could record each other at the shows
and then you'd get my video view I'd get
your video of me I would I've got Oodles
of recordings of other of people at
shows I mean we had we had we had a
um people filming our entire the last
tour we did was this spring we went out
for uh uh the fall of ideals uh
anniversary tour and uh we were out for
two months and we had film crew with us
the entire time and we were filming and
taking video and stuff so there's plenty
of video of people filming our guys
filming them do you ever take camera out
on stage and film the audience and all
that live Instagram all that 360 cameras
on the stick and stuff so yeah we've
done a bunch of that stuff it's super
cool a bunch of that's on our Tick Tock
the uh it's tick tock.com All That
Remains or whatever I thought this Elon
thing was kind of blown out of the
booing kind of thing was blown out of
proportion it didn't feel like the crowd
was booing it was a lot of mixed
emotions did you guys see the video Elon
said it was like 10 booing yeah and then
the left started saying like haha he's
lying and it's like or I don't know why
would he lie and they're like he was
booed off stage he's like no I actually
just stood there for a little while like
what did you think he was coming on
stage to do anyway yeah I mean it's not
like he's going to get up there and
transform into a Tesla or something yeah
or even make jokes he was just that's
why I'm like you know it's kind of weird
that he called him on stage in the first
place but he did yeah what do you expect
from Elon but they wanted this narrative
this is why I was complaining about uh
crap out of battery Twitter file
released on Saturday evening so uh we're
we're at Korean barbecue having dinner
and I'm like it's not it's not about the
fact that it's the like the weekend it's
about dinner time you know when when
Elon did the Twitter spaces on a
Saturday I was at Whole Foods doing my
grocery shopping and I'm listening the
whole time and I'm like and I'm tweeting
I'm like this is big news but they put
out a story the Twitter files that were
was like medium tier news on a Saturday
during dinner time and it's like okay
now you've just killed that story it was
it wasn't the strongest Twitter file to
begin with they put out a time to ensure
nobody would ever see it and remember
what it was and then the next day
Elon goes on stage with Dave Chappelle
if you wanted to make sure a story dies
that was a Master Class
and now interesting what were Saturday's
Twitter files again uneventful I have no
idea I didn't look at him until later so
they they could have waited for that
news cycle for today we wouldn't have
had as big of a news story I guess
because the the next one they released
was bigger well my next question is did
you catch the Twitter files on Saturday
how were they weren't they uh I I
vaguely remember them because we were
sitting down it was at seven something
it was like 6 30. we're sitting down to
have dinner on a weekend and then you
know I'm checking my phone all the time
and I'm reading through it and we're
waiting for food and I'm reading through
these things and then you know look try
and remember what you can when you are
eating dinner that's that's the thing
it's not just about being on the weekend
like when like I mentioned when Elon did
the Twitter spaces on the weekend it was
a huge story what he was talking about
so you know we're all there for it a
huge huge Twitter space is a hundred
thousand people but when they put out a
smaller story on a Saturday at dinner
time it's just like you've just executed
the story yeah it was a nice dinner we
had though
um so good
garlic no I was kind of reading halfway
too but it was kind of difficult because
you're there at the table and you got
really good food and you're just trying
to relax and it you know sometimes you
just can't be glue to the phone all the
time and usually that's that's the
weekend is when people usually put down
the phone and when people uh especially
you know in the Jewish faith kind of sit
down with their family members and hang
out with them and and and spend time
with family and friends
the big issue for me is I would love
nothing more than to work on weekends
and I used to
but anybody who works in PR marketing
media otherwise knows it's everyone else
who will not listen to a word you have
to say on Saturday it's Saturday so I
say okay fine I'm gonna go get dinner
I put out a video on a Saturday it's the
views of the lowest of any day of the
week it's that that's marketing 101.
PR's if you want the big press release
it's Tuesday at 11 Tuesday at noon or
something like that so Monday it was
Monday I think at 1 pm that's a really
really great time to drop a story I mean
got it I enjoy the break I enjoy being
able to clear my mind not think about
anything political I might share a meme
or two but other than that I'm like I
don't wanna I don't want to get into
this kind of larger political social
psychology of what's really going on I
just kind of want to get away from it
all disassociate and and take a breather
you gotta like I said mind rest if
someone was singing I was given in my
own a couple days ago I was telling you
um and then you just gotta let the next
day just got to do nothing just like
meditation because this is this is this
is my life as soon as I wake up all the
way till I go to sleep if like six days
a week so Saturday is my only day off so
I I try to enjoy it as much as I'm
talking about singing singing there's
there's a physical aspect with singing
too it's there's a certain amount of of
recovery that your vocal cords need so
it's not just a matter of
you know mental or or psychological
tiredness from from that kind of stuff
it really matters uh you know how much
effort you're putting in or how much
work you're putting on your your vote
chords and I think your brain also works
in the same way where you gotta we gotta
you gotta relax we gotta meditate you
gotta take some time off because if your
brain is always running running but also
during the day having some meaningful
time to be able to sit down and be in
quiet I think it's one of the most
underrated super powerful actions that
many human beings should be taking but
sadly aren't and there isn't even a
moment in time where a lot of people
have quiet they always have something
playing in the background they always
have some kind of TV on or some kind of
YouTube video on and I think that is
also distracting people from the larger
power of what is now also gut I think
your gut needs a rest from time to time
because yeah that's why fasting has been
has been found to be so beneficial and
good for people just like the muscles of
neurons and they need to rest the brain
has neurons the stomach as neurons the
heart has neurons the heart needs to
rest from time to time probably stress
just turn your heart off you know just
relax but I think if cutting out food I
don't want to give my heart any rest I I
I'm going to push back on that idea I
don't want my heart to stop well it
needs no no not stop stop but it needs
to be rested all right just chill out I
think that's dietary let's jump to this
big news ladies and gentlemen Sam
bankman freed arrested in the Bahamas I
am astounded that it took this long they
were apparently Democrats were like well
we're not going to go after them we're
not it's like okay we get it he gave you
money unbelievable unbelievable Martin
shkreli said that it could take them up
to five years to prosecute so he was
like a couple days ago I think on his
YouTube channel was saying it's not that
big of a deal they took four four years
and nine months to go after him is what
he was saying but uh then the next thing
I saw as he's arrested how long did it
take him to go after a Bernie Madoff
good question right away so as soon as
they found out but he was doing that how
long was he doing exactly but but we
found out about this scam a while they
had a chance to lawyer up they had a
chance to destroy evidence they had a
chance to cover up their tracks They had
a chance they lured up with Elaine
Maxwell's lawyers okay yeah so they have
some of the most powerful attorneys in
the world right now working with them as
they had an advantage to be able to do a
lot of crazy stuff that they could have
hidden so much they could have covered
up so much they could have got the lava
bit they could have got so many
different
actions that that could have derailed
the the larger possible Justice here and
I truly do believe that it's only
because of the pressure only because of
the coverage of independent journalists
specifically on Twitter that made them
do something and if it wasn't for this
particular pressure from Twitter from
Independent Media I wouldn't see them
doing anything it was broken by a
Twitter user wasn't it just a I think it
was crypto boy or something was the
guy's name yeah there was there was a
Twitter user uh that followed some leads
or whatever and and started exposing it
and started really uh putting out the
the information on Sam bankman freed and
and
autism Capital also did a bunch of good
work on it and it was these like it was
like these independent
um Twitter users and Elon started
picking the independent Twitter users
that's the internet man come on I love
it hey they're serious groups
autism Capital exposed it like right
when the crash was happening there was a
hack at FTX and 300 million dollars in
crypto disappeared off their Network
good I want to know where that money
went that I find that money and bring it
back I think that Sam should have to I
don't want to see him get his life
annihilated I want to see him pay those
people back yeah but how
raise crowdfund the money you know
people obviously Sam like if he knows
enough people that he's paying hundreds
of millions to like Democratic don't
time for the Democracy to get back to
Sam pay him back the thing is like I
don't know well I mean I don't know I
don't know enough about the actual the
actual scheme that he had going on to to
speak on and so I can't really say but I
just can't imagine him I know that he
was lying about having the money so I
can't imagine him being able to produce
the money that he stole I I just don't
see how anyone would would I mean who's
gonna fund him yeah I don't know I
suggested what if we use tax money and I
was like you status you communist no
well I mean I was like okay what if we
do a crowdfunding campaign to help these
people out because there's people about
to that lost like their own their last
seventy thousand dollars it was all on
FTX announced at zero yeah I lost 100
bucks I was mad like some people lost
everything what happened like he was
logging your account yeah I tried to
take my hundred dollars out and it's so
similar to The Great Depression what
happened when all these margin calls got
pulled back all these people were
investing on margin loans and then when
the when the crash happens you lose they
call your margin they take your money to
pay it pay off the undervalued asset or
whatever
and these people it's a different
situation because he was actually it
looks like he was advertently frauding
his investors he was telling him your
money's going to be safe in this account
at FDX but what's happening is they're
funneling it to Alameda research and
then using that to invest wait wait
until people find out about the American
banking system
the American the American banking system
is backed by nuclear weapons no one's
going to do anything with anyone's gonna
do anything about the American banking
system
man I I
really do want to see Sam pay these
people back I think the righteous things
they only pay like a few cents an hour
in jail though
he's got to raise the money he's got to
know people well no hold on you know a
few billion hours well a few hundred
billion hours and maybe he can pay
something or at least pay back the small
investors the people that were in for
like nine grand and that was all they
had
and now they're working paycheck to
paycheck again making like a thirty
dollars a week you know extra than what
they can afford or something like that
like people it's cold it's cold outside
it's not it's got to do something we can
do something what I I don't know what I
don't know what there is to be done
um I think the best thing that I don't
know that there is I don't know that
there is anything that can be done to
the people that lost money
uh to me I don't think there's anything
that can be done to make them whole
um
yeah I don't see him I don't I'm sure
I'm sure when you signed up too you
signed an agreement saying that you
recognize risk and blah blah but they
were blatantly told we are not touching
your money FTX will not touch this money
it's going into an account it's going to
be safe we're gonna hold it and give it
back to you and they were taking it into
this other what sludge funds that they
had where like all the money was mixed
together and this thing is that's why
Sam bankman freed needs to suffer not
physically suffer but suffer it needs to
in there needs to be there needs to be
repercussions that disincentivize people
from doing what he did now the
honeypot's big because you're talking
about billions of dollars so the payoff
is really really really really worth the
risk to a lot of to a lot of people but
if you make the penalty you know bad
enough
hopefully it would deter people I don't
think it will man you know we've got
there's always going to be people that
are going to break the law right you
know you know we've got Chicago you've
got gun laws you got murder laws you got
death penalty and people are just oh is
Illinois death penalty I'm pretty sure
Illinois is that penalty right electric
chair I don't know maybe you're right
not because it is it is a blue State
yeah and to be honest with you even if
even if it is it is death penalty most
of your your your street crime like that
doesn't get death penalty because
usually it has to be something like
premeditated murder or something oh yeah
no since 2011 no more death penalty okay
yeah so there you go so um I've just
I've looked at that stuff and I just
don't I don't think criminal charges
deter people from committing crimes
they're supposed to they're supposed to
but they they do I think I think the
issue with all the crime we've seen and
the collapse that we're seeing in this
country is is based on a lack of
community that people don't respect each
other they don't fear each other they
don't care used to be that the reason
you wouldn't Rob your neighbor's house
was because you were scared about what
your neighbors would say when they found
out you were a robber you would be able
to go to the grocery store then you
would be able to buy bread or meat now
it's just you go to a city and they're
like don't know you don't care yes Sam's
lack of compassion for the people that
used ftx's Stark he's done a lot of
interviews which people have said this
is this is a terrible move for someone
right after they commit a multi-billion
dollar uh fraud like he did or at least
I don't know if it's is it is it okay to
say he committed fraud oh yes even if I
don't I mean just looks like he admitted
it on to Coffee Zilla and Twitter yeah
he said he said what he did was wrong he
said that you know what he did qualifies
as fraud what he admitted to
meets the definition of Fraud so it's
okay to call it fraud see a patsy is
there somebody else that's stalls Mike
because he doesn't seem like the
smartest guy you know he's playing
videos now but yeah he was known as like
the next yeah Warren Buffett they were
saying yeah who was saying that someone
media organization
probably probably yeah yeah some of the
most discredited name names in corporate
media he was financing a lot of the the
media organizations just like Bill Gates
he was giving them a lot of money that
money buys you a lot of influence and
then the corporate media kisses your ass
let's be real it seems like if you do
the opposite of dream what Jim Cramer
says you'll be rich yeah they're they're
I believe there are Bots that counter
trade Jim Cramer the universe you know
what I'm going at this as I hope that
people get their money back but you're
right Phil he needs there needs to be
strict harsh penalties for what he did
because he defrauded billions of dollars
out of I don't know how many tens of
thousands of humans lost their life
savings how many thousands maybe we got
to bring back some unusual punishment
you know like tarring and Feathering
something like that I mean you could you
could make an argument to allow the
people that he actually defrauded to
take it into their own hands but I mean
yeah that's not a good argument or it's
not a good it's not a good solution but
it's a solution that might deter people
if you know every everyone you defraud
gets to beat the absolute crap out of
you we're in the age of like impact
investment right now where people think
the ends justify the means if we're
giving to things we believe in then if
other people get screwed along the way
it's worth it I think that's Sam's sick
mentality I mean how many what many
drugs was he using different do you
think that that I I don't know if he's
made any remarks uh about this uh other
than he the fact that I've read
headlines that talked about his
philanthropy I I read I don't remember
who wrote the the headline but I I
recall a headline that was something
like this is going to mess up his
ability to to uh do the the projects
that he was looking to help people
um I it was one of the more sycophantic
headlines I've ever seen about a person
that was accused of such such a
dramatic Financial crime but they call
it I think it was something like now his
dream projects won't be visualized
I mean it's not philanthropy they use
this cover word in order to just buy
people off and I mean especially when it
comes to the whole non-profit sector
there's a lot of criminals in that whole
sector that are just acting like they're
giving away their money when in reality
they're just making money for themselves
you'll get Bill Gates he was like I'm
gonna give away all my money he doubled
his money since saying that a couple
years ago that's not a coincidence it's
not an accident and I think you know
they're thinking deeper here I think
there's a big possibility that this SPF
guy was a patsy he was the last man
holding the bag and that there was a
bigger operation at hand here that was
moving around the billions of dollars in
secret shadow funds that uh are still
unaccounted for they call it the global
corporations are calling it um impact
investment where you invest in things
that you want to see happen regardless
of the return on your investment it's
just about giving money to things you
believe in in the tech sector they're
calling it effective altruism they're
they're mutilating the word altruism and
saying if there's a net benefit if we
have to hurt 99 people but we help 100
it's worth it it's effectively
altruistic yeah to me that's that's
utilitarianism yeah it is absolutely
utilitarianism and a lot of people got
hurt in this risk it's like unnecessary
risk like Thanos like like Thanos from
Marvel you know he wants to save the
universe by killing half of them right
there you go
you're about to follow up there's some
people that are making an argument now
hey you know what you should make uh
well I don't know if the meme translates
if like some kind of Bargain Bin Thanos
is Bill Gates what expectation versus
reality Nano snapping and then in
reality it's Bill Gates going oh there
are too many people and that's what you
get let's talk about this story here the
snap and then there's just like weird uh
mosquitoes that are flying around let's
go fly out here we go from The Daily
Mail
Biden's non-binary nuclear waste worker
Sam Brinton leaves the department of
energy after being accused of stealing
suitcases from two airports let me stop
you there Daily Mail he wasn't accused
he was criminally charged and he's on
camera doing it you even posted the
videos oh no they didn't post the videos
here maybe uh if we refresh it we'll get
something
uh well no they're just him wearing a
dress there we go they posted the actual
photo of him stealing some woman's
luggage so I guess what they're saying
now and then here's him look at this
here's him wearing this shirt in an
airport stealing the bag and then here's
him posting a selfie confirming it was
in fact him wearing that Sam that's not
yours put it back so what they're saying
now is
they're saying he's not nine not not
non-binary he gets off on stealing
women's clothes and then wearing them in
public and making people watch him do it
so it's like a klepto fetish thing
that's so weird when this guy joins
really Department well he's on camera to
get more than once stealing women's
clothing
okay I want you to be right because
that's that's I'm not saying I I know
for sure I'm saying this is what people
are saying now about what's happening
that's a better story than non-binary
this the speculation is non-binary is
boring now there's plenty of people out
there the speculation is that he steals
women's clothing and gets off on having
people watch him wear it so it's not
about gender identity it's about him
stealing from them and then you know so
it's like Auto gynophilia where he's
just walking around
wait yeah
he's walking around kind of kind of
walking around with someone else's stuff
like semi-hard Auto kleptophilia I don't
know what I don't know I don't know no
that would be like stealing from
yourself
because you're stealing
voyeuristic right is that is that where
you want people to watch you yeah yeah
it'd be a klepto voyeuristic Auto kind
of feeling no exhibitionist no wait is
exhibitionist
because we said before and someone
claimed like no no you have it backwards
what's the is there a word for there's
not a uh would be someone that wants to
watch a voye would be someone that wants
to be one so it's exhibitionist he wants
to be watched yeah so it's exhibitionist
klepto autogynophilia he likes attention
yeah dude when he it is it is he right
we're not misgendering him I think
that's safe
I don't know either sexual male I just
don't want some identifies this I still
want someone to be able to be like oh
you were misgendering him and like make
the focus the fact that there was a
Mischief you focus on sex the biology of
this guy when he was born was male and I
think he is at some point transitioned
his gender to CIS oh yeah yeah not it's
nonsense voyeurism is when you get off
watching other people yeah so
exhibitionist is I think right when he
joined the Biden Administration I was
kind of like this end game yes yes I
guess we get people like this with
lipstick ball guy looking weird
he doesn't know what's in this in the
White House
you know it'll be a lot funnier if it
turns out that like his early life story
was that he was like a skydiver and a
snowboarder and he gets off on
adrenaline rushes crazier the better man
so he just like steals women's clothing
I love it and then he's like he's
wearing the evidence of his felonies and
he's getting an adrenaline rush from
people watching him do it dude hey he's
a more honest politician than the other
politicians in Washington DC okay it was
a bureaucrat not a politician he's worse
yeah
even still I I'm I mean I have to give
this this story two thumbs up because
I'm enjoying it so much I'm I appreciate
your service it feels like re like I've
been praying and this is kind of what
happens when you pray is that people be
I'm praying that someone that works for
the government steals women's bags the
clothes
you got there people reveal who they
really are when you're deep in prayer
with God people start to reveal who they
really are and people like this this
thief uh is now now it's apparent that
he's a thief yeah so that's good this is
like stealing someone's like he stole
bags that were worth thousands of
dollars it's like it's demonic but in
not like the worst way like demonic that
freaks me out as well demonic in the
most Bourgeois way yeah like you know
demonic usually I'm imagining Epstein
stuff like high level demonic satanic
evil this is like Mischief yeah you know
stealing the person's luggage that's
freak that might have been insulin in
there I don't know it might have been
something and that guy didn't even check
in with the bag but walked out with one
well not I don't I don't think insulin
because it has to be refrigerated
probably not inside something
life-saving something here put it in the
thermos yeah hopefully you'll check that
stuff but there might be stuff you need
that you can't chat or that you can't
hopefully you'll take that off yeah you
know people are sometimes they're
addicted to like painkillers so what
happens if someone had their painkillers
inside of you know one of the you know
luggages stealing a bag from a store I
understand it's not it's not like you're
beating someone's face in but stealing
someone's personal belonging is very
different than stealing something from a
store in my opinion evil people man yeah
I'm glad it's crazy like I said I I I'm
happy that it happened because I get to
imbibe the story and enjoy it but that's
the extent of it so he's on leave now no
longer an employee
that's just and criminally charged yeah
your employees what going to prison I'm
gonna get locked up well it depends on
Larson Attorney that he gets the crazy
thing is apparently the first time
Brenton got caught doing this he told
the cop like oh I accidentally grabbed
the wrong bad bag and didn't realize it
and then I panicked because people
thought I stole it so I just left it and
then I brought it back to the airport or
whatever and it's like bro you're on
camera with no bag and that was the day
he didn't he didn't check a bag
you go to the airport with no bag and
you take someone's bag we know you stole
it yep at the very least you know like
he could get a uh a generic black travel
bag but the dude just not even smart
enough to do that he got caught twice
now imagine how many times he wasn't
caught because how many times will
officers or security actually go through
the whole footage actually look at uh
the whole scenario and actually do a
full investigation to find out who stole
a luggage bag I mean I I had a bag once
missing and they were like yeah screw
you tough luck yep so how many times did
he get away with it is the larger
question I want it to be double digits
and I want to hear about every one of
them
I would I'd be willing to bet the
clothing he's wearing all the time his
clothing he stole from women God I hope
that's true
because I think it's hilarious crazy
story I just like the fact that it's a
crazy chaotic story like so outlandish
this this person gets hired and then
just flies around the country stealing
people's bags and wears clothing of the
opposite sex and and then wears a lot of
weird dog stuff too I mean oh yeah
there's a lot of dog stuff yeah not a
dog master I I love him I love him bald
dude with lipstick he looks like Matt
Damon too
absolutely like sorry Matt or
congratulations Matt
congratulations nice job guys yeah he
looks like a bald Matt Damon maybe Matt
can play him in the movie oh there we go
it'll be the older Britain is that his
name the older Prince about the dude
who's the whole luggage from the airport
yeah
how did I get here
Phil's dying get it you can't do it
can we hire Matt Damon to do this maybe
at some point did he do an FTX
commercial he did not oh he did I don't
know but no he did a crypto commercial
was it was it I don't know yes
that was crypto.com
people are getting sued Like Larry David
for this FDX thing Larry David are they
actually getting sued you guys know I
don't know I think so but it's kind of
dumb like doing a commercial is not the
same as like running and committing the
fraud you know for sure yeah like
there's no way these guys knew this it's
a crypto exchange yeah and the exchange
outwardly said they were going to do it
righteously and they lied if the if this
change had been saying they're gonna do
it illegally and then you know Tom Brady
was still doing commercials for him he'd
be implicated in my opinion
well Tom Brady was an investor he's
probably super angry about that I mean
just like not only the people that had
no money in FTX but it's also the people
that were investors you know that's why
him and uh Giselle are getting divorced
yeah she's mad she's like I can't
believe you Tom no no she was she was
the one who pushed him to do it that
idea and she's like just do it honey I'm
the one that makes the money in this
family here with your stupid football
she makes so much more money than he
does he was able to take a low contract
because of that yeah the Patriots have a
huge amount of money to spend on players
nice I got a uh you know Media Matters
is mad at me because I I was talking
about what story were we talking about I
think it was Elon or something yeah it's
the Elon story I said woke people want
companies to keep on bad employees based
on their identity yeah they do and and
the left got mad at me for saying that
but I'm like but that's a fact statement
that's your that's true Media Matters is
always mad at someone they're they're I
my favorite person in Media Matters is
the girl that watches Tucker Carlson her
whole job is just to watch Tucker
Carlson and be a [ __ ] and I'm like
you're the best I love her she's great
who is it her name her name's Kat yeah
and she works for Media Matters her job
is to watch Tucker Carlson and be and
just be a complete we should do that we
should just hire someone well there are
people that do that I mean there's
there's people that watch like medium
like me matter stuff and like Sean
actual Justice Warrior he's great all
his job is just a sh crap all over The
Young Turks we got we got to do like a
Mystery Science Theater thing with MSNBC
where we just get like people to watch
it and comment on it in real time it
would be so much fun probably get three
comedians just watch you know Rachel
Maddow specials Joy Reid I wouldn't Joy
read I wouldn't wish you embarrassing on
anyone are you kidding me that's
hilarious yeah seriously Joy Reed says
the most ridiculous [ __ ] it would be
freaking awesome to have three
Silhouettes just sitting there trashing
every ridiculous thing that comes out of
her mouth
Joy Reid huh yeah she's great she got
hacked once
oh wait you remember that story oh she
actually tweeted something and then said
it was a hack no she posted a Blog that
was like opposing gay marriage or
something yeah and then she's like they
they hacked they hacked me they hacked
me then you want to be like who's they
Joy but who's they though
what do you mean Joy
that's the crazy thing about uh uh
modern cancel culture stuff is that
these people know that the top the whims
of the left rotate randomly and so they
have to say something today that they
have to disagree with tomorrow
so then they just deny it I'd break up a
reason I don't really say that I was
hacked
like is it is a system that's trying to
constantly uh subvert the system and if
the system changes it needs to create a
different type of subversion so you're
always the continuous Revolution as soon
as something becomes
old as soon as something becomes the
norm or part of the status quo then it
becomes
counter-revolutionary and so they have
the the revolutionaries have to oppose
anything that's considered uh status quo
so it's all it's all about constantly
performing the dialectic or constantly
pushing the envelope constantly being a
revolutionary that's why when you listen
to like uh when you listen to old videos
of like Castro talking or whatever he's
always talking about counter
revolutionaries and the revolution
continues like the revolution happened
Castro got into power in Cuba and then
you listen to Castro talk for the next
whatever 60 or whatever years however
long he was he was alive it's the
revolution the revolution the revolution
the revolution it's continuous it it's
it's constant if it stops if the
revolution ends then it becomes the
status quo it becomes conservative it
becomes the old things and the bad you
know and that's all the bad stuff
according to you know the
revolutionaries so staying on the
offensive psychologically I I think that
might be might be accurate I'm not sure
if that's the way they conceive of it
um but if you're a revolutionary leftist
then you need to make sure that the
revolution is continuous somebody said
that Biden's person looks like the
daughter from Coneheads
that's the first thing I thought when I
saw this guy
oh okay all right but I don't think they
look alike they just have Coneheads yeah
they all have lipstick on I'm going to
stand on principle and not mock people
that are bald thank you very much
I am in no position to mock anyone yeah
that's that's not it though is it a
cone-shaped head or not that's the
question and but more importantly the
the young woman who well actually I
don't think she's young anymore but the
one who played the daughter in the
conehead doesn't look like that guy
what's who is that not at all yeah
someone just super chatted that they
were like looks like the daughter I
don't know he does have like a very
conical stream side by side I wanna part
of me wants to make fun of Sam Britton
because I he I think he looks like funny
kind of like you know he wears big bald
head lipstick wearing women's clothes
like that for me not funny yeah
I want to stay focused on the crime that
the Biden Administration puts someone
into there I believe because of his
sexual identity or his gender identity
and then it turns out it's a thief has
made it clear that identity is the is
the most important thing and he made it
clear before he was the president he
made it clear when he said that he was
going to pick a uh a person of color
woman that a woman of color to be his
running mate he specifically said that
before he picked uh Kamala Harris like
out like there's there was no no
no ambiguity to it it was purely said
that he was going to select a woman of
color identity has been a defining
Factor throughout the whole Biden
Administration whether or not you
approve of that is a different topic but
you can't deny the fact that the Biden
Administration has made identity a
definitive uh uh aspect when it comes to
hiring yeah there's no question about
Jean-Pierre yeah he's terrible at her
job and if they cared about her skin
color her sexuality like that what you
just need I mean I don't know her
personally but she's obviously lying
she's terrible literature she looks like
she's lying a lot of times and doesn't
answer a question repeats herself goes
uh uh uh you know what I mean but I mean
what can you do at that point are you
gonna be like yeah actually the
administration's full of it you can't I
mean you're supposed to be the
mouthpiece of the dog you know I don't
know Katie mcenany
she went and she did a really really
great job and Donald Trump did his
absolute best to throw that poor woman
under the bus every chance he got if you
listen to to Kaylee mcenany like dodging
not just the Press but also dodging
stuff that Donald Trump said that she
just found out about that she didn't
know about she was really really good
and she had to deal with not only a
hostile press but Donald Trump who was
completely and totally unpredictable for
for uh um a press secretary you watch
the way that she behaved compared to the
way that Jean-Pierre does her job and it
is striking the difference in
professional preparedness that Kaylee
mcanini had compared to Korean John
Prieto I get this vibe that the the
reporters in the room with her are like
I'm so lucky to be here if I upset the
queen we will be ostracized and and
banished and so when when Korean gets
angry if you see her her face or get
contort like that's her about to be like
you're out of here if you do if you
don't shut up you're out of here I
imagine that the DNC the people that
that are in the The Press Room in the
White House are mostly Democrats and
they don't want to I mean it's all about
access they don't want to upset the
access that they have they don't want to
upset the the administration because if
the administration is upset with them
then they might get kicked out they
might not get the good beat they might
not get the leads they might not get the
people in the administration calling
them saying hey I've got a scoop for you
Etc et cetera that's just the way that
that kind of stuff goes when you're in
those positions accesses everything and
if you up set the president or the
administration the administration cuts
off your access and if you don't have
access then you're not valuable to the
admin the organization that you're
supposed to be the white house uh you
know liaison for or whatever we're gonna
go to super chats if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends become a member
over at timcast.com we're gonna have
that members only uncensored show coming
up tonight so if you want to hang out
with Phil and the crew for the
uncensored not family-friendly version
go to timcast.com and sign up let's read
your Super Chat smash that like button
by the way
all right Butter's Creamy Goo says any
chance you'll have the Hodge twins on
that would be amazing don't forget to
bring the goo
oh
um yes maybe I I think we're working on
someone with those with the Hodge twins
that'd be really great they're hilarious
so we'll see
Noah boa says hey Phil it's been a while
welcome back when can we expect some new
music I'm experiencing withdrawal
symptoms LOL 2023
anything more uh there's there's a
couple things that Jason has been
working on that Jason has uh put up I've
got a couple parts that I've been
messing around with
um but we don't have anything in any
kind of position to prove uh to show
anyone there is some business stuff that
we are dealing with on the back end
um that we are trying to sort out that
is also affecting release schedules
um and that is being handled as fast as
we possibly can
um but things are moving and I
understand that there are a lot of
people that are you know anticipating
the project because this will be the
first record that we do with Jason
Richardson and you know it's been a long
time since we put a record out uh so I
appreciate people that are being patient
but follow me Phil that remains on
Twitter you can follow the band All That
Remains uh and the updates will be there
stuff is coming I promise right on
Raymond g Stanley Jr says I remember
when Mr bocus would interrupt IRL J
jumping on the table to dip his head in
a glass of water Tim I really hope he
gets back to being healthy I mean it was
only about a month ago he not even a
month ago it was like two weeks ago it
was when I think when Savannah was here
he was at the door yelling to try and
come in so what happened is over the
past I guess two months we've been
noticing he had him acting a little
weird but nothing alarming and then in
the past couple of weeks I you know I
was like well a couple months ago I was
like we need to bring him to the vet we
brought him to the vet and then they
were like yeah he's okay just you know
blah blah and they missed it I guess
because it's a it's chronic kidney
disease and they they don't present
symptoms until it's getting really you
know almost too late and then uh we saw
Mr bocus was sleeping we uh we we
carried them you know into the house of
the studio we put him down and then he
just slumped onto the ground and his
head went straight to the floor in a
weird way we never saw before and I was
like okay and I picked him up placed him
on the sofa and then he started like
shaking a little bit
so we had him rushed to the ER and they
said that uh he didn't have much time
left he had like a like renal failure
and so they gave him uh we we rushed him
from there to a specialist like a
special ER bigger one where they gave
him two blood transfusions and IV fluids
which dramatically improved his
condition but they said he's in stage
three kidney failure stage four is total
kidney failure there's some stuff they
can do a hormone to generate more red
blood cells injections but even with all
the medication it's maybe a year there
is another option and it is a cat kidney
transplant
where what they do is they yeah yeah
Phil's looking at me like what no I'm
not kidding they said they're they're
specialist facilities where they'll find
a shelter cat with no family and in
exchange for you adopting it they will
do a kidney transplant to your sick cat
so that way otherwise the other cat gets
euthanized so you save two cats in the
process that is beautiful and I love
this and I'm not even a cat and it's
twenty thousand dollars oh I hate that
part that part's awful yeah man yup yup
and it's like hard to find a place that
will actually do it it's probably like a
California thing for a super rich
celebrity types
so uh you know my response is uh
adopting another cat that would
otherwise be killed Saving Mr bocus
sounds like the appropriate thing to do
um but with even one kidney they're not
gonna live that long but they'll live
and uh the other the other issue is that
um
Mr bocus has other other problems due to
being a gutter cat yes I'll continue
when when you when you rescue it comes
with health issues he's a wild cat I
don't want to interrupt you I've been
I've been crying about this actually
this is this is yeah he uh he was born
in the streets and so he has
underdeveloped kidneys which put him at
risk for kidney failure and then he's
also got a heart issue so they're like
we don't they said they don't even know
if they can give them a kidney
transplant because it's got a heart
problem so we might be able to get him
hormone treatment
IV fluids regular medicine and then
maybe he could live for another year and
he's like four years old
and binders you help clear the urine
you've been good to him like you you
said once to me that it was he he was
inside a lot and we were like gotta keep
remember you're like I think it's just
best just to let him out and live life
out there like that's no way to live for
a cat and we live on a farm I mean we
basically live out in the woods you
gotta let that guy eat parasitic rats
and whatever the hell he's doing out
there but like he's a wild man you know
so uh he was indoors all the time
sleeping and just morbidly depressed and
he would you know just never move and we
were like this is terrible like this is
not life dangerous Freedom over peaceful
slavery so we let him go outside we were
worried because like you know he's going
to get sick or something
when we first found out he got sick I
got a ton of regret like
you know uh if we cut them inside yeah
but then I but we talked about it it's
like no no no that's no way to live to
to to to lock someone up because you
don't want to be hurt is ridiculous but
then I'm like yeah but he's four he's
gonna die then when we found out
actually it seems to be genetic and he's
got underdeveloped kidneys that made me
feel even better like if we didn't let
him out and what short time what little
time he had we we locked him up the
whole time he never got to go out and
experience the joys of life that would
have made me feel worse so I think back
to uh you know when he's outside laying
in the grass and just torturing Birds he
would catch a bird and then injure it
and then just stare at it when it tried
to escape he'd run up and whack it again
and just pure torture small animals and
then I had to put the bird out of its
misery like yo like it's so brutal and
he would yell angry so uh but we'll
we'll see what happens right now he's
still in the animal hospital he's uh
they said that he has minor improvement
from the the blood transfusions
antibiotics he went from like 18 to 24
whatever that means but they think he's
in stage three failure so he's not going
to get better it's not reverse
we asked them about stem cells they said
they didn't know but apparently stem
cells are an option they do they take
they harvest the stem cells from the
animal's fat and then give and then
replicate them and then put them into
the bloodstream which regenerates organs
so um I don't know I hear good things
about stem cells maybe we got to do uh
and it's not like people think it's not
like we're like taking baby cats it's
they they harvest it from the fat cells
of the cat itself four yeah it's four
four okay yeah so it is yeah he should
be 15 20 years old but he's got a
genetic and that's what this look he's a
he was a he's a gutter cat yeah for six
months unknown who knows what he was
eating what he was going through if he
was born whatever disaster in a run
maybe he didn't was under fed for the
first six weeks of his life you know
kidneys weren't growing properly because
he wasn't eating proper diet and then we
brought him in gave him real food it
kicked him up but you can only get him
he's so friendly the night I met him he
just came right up to me one of those
cats he's uh when you it's kind of sad
because I was looking on the website if
you go to the join us become a member at
timcast he is the center column of our
of our a rock Talent roster and then we
got Roberto Jr on there as well our
rooster but uh I'm looking at the photo
of him and I was like wow that was like
six months ago and he looks so much
healthier yeah and we didn't we didn't
even realize now when you look at him
how gaunt he had gotten yeah and uh I
don't know man yeah he uh we'll read
more we'll read more Super chats here
we'll read some more Super chats
all right Glacier says Tim could you
spare some words on Brazil one of
indigenous Chieftain protesting
elections got arrested and fighting has
broken out in Brasilia it's unknown if
police have used live bolts or not wow
man so they're still they're still
fighting about uh whether or not Lula
and uh or whether whether it was oh yeah
I mean they called it for Lula I think
right but bolsonaro was contesting it or
something well I knew they called it I I
didn't know lastly I'd heard and I only
know very very little superficial uh
information about this is that like
bolsonaro conceded Lulu won and then the
people were kind of like you know
demanding the military intervened to to
deal with it because that's what their
military's supposed to do in terms of
contested election or something I don't
know uh what I do know is I love Brazil
I have been there several times I
actually have a visa to Brazil which uh
you know you have to apply to get yeah
and uh it's amazing you've been I love
it it's it's absolutely awesome so it's
sad to see what's going on there I hope
things get better yeah
it's great it's a lot of fun I've had
really really good times when I'm too
much fun in Brazil for me yeah oh really
Copacabana man just sitting on the beach
was better for me I liked it way better
Sao Paulo was way better the difference
absolutely uh the people the culture the
just the energy the vibe in Rio you kind
of got to look over your back the whole
time you're there shout out in Sao Paulo
you do but in certain areas but mostly
you're fine I liked I liked Copacabana
shout out to uh hafina bastos for those
that are familiar with his work he's a
very famous Brazilian comedian I did an
interview with him a few months ago so
he's doing some uh like he's working up
in New York a little bit he's got like a
studio but he's like I think he's still
based in Brazil I'm not sure what's
what's going on but I hung out at his
Comedy Club when I went down there the
first time cool stuff I had a nice
Brazilian girlfriend as soon as I went
down there oh yeah all right Michael
Diamond says I was amazed to see Elon
following and responding to Luke today
congrats what was that tweet exactly too
you made a good point and he basically
agreed with your point oh it's nothing
we're just like you know best friends I
think you were saying the future of
humanity either we're about to awaken as
a species or everything's falling gonna
fall apart there's a point that I made
on the show a couple of days ago
specifically saying we're either in the
worst of times or the best of times
we're either in a mass Awakening or
we're in a total societal collapse so we
were talking about it a few days ago and
it just kind of reminded me what he was
saying and that's why I kind of
responded to him essentially saying the
same thing but saying it in a different
way Alpha Freedom Fighter says hey Tim I
finally got my CCW in New Jersey holy
yeah wow I can't believe that
congratulations is that because of the
Supreme Court ruling I guess does that
mean that he actually threw the One Ring
into the lava in Mortar yeah that's how
you get it right you have to throw the
One Ring into the love and actually
destroy it you have to travel Barefoot
yeah for three months three months two
more they're not banning guns no it's
just it takes you three months you gotta
travel to the center of mountain Doom
but uh I suppose this means that the
Supreme Court ruling saying they can't
deny it anymore has forced New Jersey to
start granting people uh Concealed Carry
Permits thank goodness hey that's that's
fantastic
all right five against eight says come
on Phil when Luke asks for a war cry I
expect something crispy like the
beginning of this calling LOL huge All
That Remains fans since the darkened
heart great to see you back on IRL My
Two Worlds colliding cheers we could do
it at the end of the show all right
remember we'll save for the members only
we'll get a you know well no all right
get the crispy ones the crispy one
all right we'll grab some more Super
chats where are we at
simulant says you guys should get
coffeezilla in here for a talk he's
doing great work exposing crypto scams
and was able to get SBF to pretty much
admit fraud interesting coffee Zillow is
the guy on a call on a Twitter space is
the one that he asks Sam directly if
they'd co-mingled funds and Sam said
that they had wow is coffeezilla that
was he the act the
the dude that that broke the story well
I don't think no okay but he's just a
journalist that's gone deep in the last
three weeks he went on Lex Friedman
about four days ago I saw a small clip
of of the Lex Friedman thing and it was
pretty pretty impressive yeah I I
haven't heard of him before but I think
it would be great to have a conversation
with him because there's a lot of scans
and scammers out there it's crazy and
and speaking of coffee I have two two uh
medium tier announcements we've got the
location for our soon to be uh Cafe it's
going to be epic there's a multi-story
building Cafe first floor games and
skate shop second floor and then
probably recording studio in the top
floor nice it's gonna be super awesome
so where's it gonna be uh I can't I
don't want to say just yet but West
Virginia okay
um and we I think we're gonna actually
have we're going to be able to uh
announce the coffee for the coffee shop
soon so we have Graphics I'm really
excited for um
uh I'll just say it I'm just going to
say it I don't know I might piss people
off we're working on it because I'm you
know but I can't I can't keep it in it's
a rise with Roberto Jr breakfast blend
nice so yeah Roberto Junior's on the bag
perfect you know I was like it's a
rooster you know you wake up and he's
like your coffee very cocky cocky of you
Tim I'm so excited because I just want
to have tons of those bags and like
Roberto Jr on it and the rooster
that's cool yeah but the reason we
decided to to do our own brand of coffee
was because we wanted to open a coffee
shop I've been talking about that all
year just to go just to mess with the
quartering right no no no no no like uh
I actually talked to him and we were
talking about actually using coffee
brand coffee as our supplier oh quick
and uh uh it it may happen in the future
but I don't think it can happen now just
because he's further away yeah there's a
lot of logistical issues and uh the cost
associated with it but we talked about
it and I was like I don't want to use
any other company other than coffee
brand coffee because we want to build a
parallel economy out we went over the
numbers and for a variety of reasons
notably like shipping and location it's
like you guys are East Coast he's
Midwest it's probably not as easy and
then I was like let's Circle back in
like six to 12 months and figure out if
we can go from there so we have a
supplier East Coast to to do
distribution uh for us but uh we're only
we're only doing a few basic Blends and
it's it's because we're gonna have the
coffee shop so you know we have like a
light dark and medium roast and then we
have like like my favorite which is like
psychotically dark yeah super dark
awesome I love it yeah yeah it's gonna
always lighten it up but you can't make
it darker
yeah no I love it's true very very dark
roast it's like maximum Darkness it's
gonna be fantastic not burned but very
dark black you can call it the blackest
pillars
you know what we're doing with it is not
political like rise with Roberto Jr it's
just you know we're gonna have a coffee
shop the coffee Shop's not gonna be
political one of the things we're going
to do goth roast goth roast yeah but one
of the things I want to do is actually
whenever you purchase something we're
gonna figure it out you get to uh play a
game of craps I'm quote unquote street
dice and uh you can you get a chance to
win a free coffee so we thought it would
be fun to like some kind of game where
you can come in and just like when you
buy something you can roll the die and
if 7 or 11 comes up you get a free
coupon for a coffee or whatever that's
cool yeah something like that and then
you could actually bet on specific
numbers of people who know to play craps
yeah we'll totally get it you could be
like you know I want to put my coupon on
Yo and then it's like 15 cups of coffee
if you roll 11 and then it's like you
put your put your uh coupon on Aces it's
like 30 cups of coffee you get a gift
card for that or 30 gift card or
something like that so it's a good idea
that's a really good idea well the whole
point of the place is not to like make
become ultra wealthy of a coffee shop
it's to make a community center where
people can hang out and have a good time
so we're setting up in one part of it
Ian's Crystal Cove oh let's get a
crystal ball in there yes and what it's
going to be is the way the building it's
an L-shaped building so the L portion is
going to be curtained off and when you
go in there's going to be crystals and
like lights
hanging and then there'll be like a
movie playing and you can sit down and
like read a book with a lamp and have
your coffee in a quieter chill Crystal
what's really good is uh all I can think
of is the the scene from uh
from Mall Rats when when Jay and Silent
Bob went to the dirt mall and they sat
down with the uh the the psychic woman
and I just imagine
Ian in in like in in the room obviously
not with a third nipple like clothes I
don't know that
just imagine Ian in there you know
sitting there with the coffee around him
just kind of vibing out like in chainsaw
or like small rats yeah and we could do
um hookahs you guys ever oh yeah I guess
it's technically not smoking hookah you
know vaping I don't know if we would do
who does coffee it's gonna be an Ian
kind of space with rocks and dye and
stuff and you know you can it's
basically a place where it's like dip
like if you're in the main area it's
well lit then you go through the
curtains and it's dimly lit with a movie
playing and it's very very chill but
then upstairs you walk up the stairs and
there's going to be a skate shop section
and like board games table games and
some skee ball so it's really just about
creating a place it's fun to go and hang
out yeah because my whole thing is like
when you're done with work and you've
taken care of your chores and stuff and
you just want to chill what do you do
and so there's a variety of things
people do and I'm like well you should
need like a like a cool hangout spot so
you'll have a coffee downstairs it's
gonna be very very simple it's gonna be
like coffee and cappuccinos you know
latte espressos nothing super fancy and
then there's like there's food across
the street you can bring your own food
or whatever yeah we could work out with
local restaurants to have delivery on
demand yeah you have a rest revenue and
you can pick from four different
restaurants we're gonna have a stage so
we can do comedy and and music stuff but
let's read some more that's cool first
Thessalonians says Elon Musk is a
globalist advancing the great reset he
was part of the 2008 young global
leaders he is the enemy I've heard that
a lot of people have oh actually imagine
Nawaz is extremely concerned about this
Elon love right now because for similar
reasons how old is Elon my guess 52 15
51 Elon Musk age 51 what's he got give
me your guesses give me your guesses 51
born in 71 so 51. I see 51.
good job yeah I I did the price of right
thing that Ian oh you undercut Me by one
are you supposed to go over by one I
guess that way if he's older than it no
actually I did the inverse prices right
thing I was probably hurting myself by
giving myself no no room I wasn't aware
uh that he was a young World economic
Forum leader I'm gonna try I'm gonna try
to fact check that right now but I
haven't heard of it personally myself so
I don't know if it's true or not you
know I I think there certainly are a
bunch of musk Bros or whatever people
who are just like defending him no
matter what but there's there's people
like that for everybody Trump's got his
people Bernie's got his people so I'm
not
you know it is what it is I think he's
doing good things and I'll take it I'll
take the win you celebrate people when
they do good things you criticize them
when they do bad things and more
importantly you never put anyone above
yourself yeah yeah I I don't I don't
aside from the the the culture War
implications I don't see what people
could be really significantly upset with
Elon Musk about right like I If you're
in you know knee-deep in the culture war
and you're on the left I get it he
represents the things that you're
opposed to so that at least I can wrap
my head around but if you're not steeped
in the culture War
I don't understand what it is that
people find objectionable about Elon
Musk like if you're if you're not on
Twitter and you're not involved in the
culture War other than like you know
what you see and hear on the news what
is it about Elon Musk that you could in
the past six months now decide okay this
guy embodies all of the bad things that
I used to place on Donald Trump yeah you
know let's rate this one we got this
from Bronson Holland says happy to see a
Metalhead on the show again with that
said from a professional standpoint how
full of soy is heavy metal in your
opinion
uh it is just like every other thing
there is a or at least it's just like
head down the middle like there's like a
woke contingent and well I say I think
it's probably like every other thing in
entertainment so it's heavily heavily
left-leaning because it's entertainment
it's so weird but but yeah I mean
there's I mean I've had hit pieces done
on me by you know blogs that are
straight up communist the blog has like
the sickle and Hammer uh you know up and
and complains about Donald Trump like
right after Trump was elected and and uh
there's other guys in blogs that are act
like their their name in their name they
had actual so like socialist Pig and
stuff like that so it's just as as
heavily influenced by the left in the
metal Community as you know as any other
art would be you know whether it be rock
or pop or or whatever do you find that
the metal gets hotter when you eat meat
and keep like a heavily heavy meat based
diet no no I don't I don't I don't I
don't ascribe to the idea that uh
personality has much influence on your
ability to write heavy stuff the the
there's this meme of going around that I
saw where where it's just like it's this
dude that looks like he's from the
Revenge of the Nerds and it says if your
guitar player looks like this you're
about to die in that pit and it's true
because if you if your guitar players
got horn Rim glasses they're probably
like math nerds and they probably wrote
some kind of crazy breakdown and dudes
that look like mountains are gonna smash
your face in because some dude that
looks like you know Poindexter wrote
some crazy riffs that's true all right
it really is Eric Miller says Mars
doesn't have gas stations so electric
cars boring company handles the drilling
he also has robots which doesn't require
oxygen to work yep everything musk is
doing is all a part of getting us to
Mars I mean he's talked about it over
and over and over again it's all about
making Interstellar human beings because
like so like the idea that like oh we
have to save the planet because the the
idea is essentially like well for some
of them some of them think that the
human race should die off so maybe this
is an incomplete thought here um or not
well thought out but the whole idea that
like saving the human race Save the
Planet to save the human race the best
way to save the human race is to make
sure the human race isn't limited to the
Earth because eventually the sun is
gonna turn into a red giant and swallow
the the Earth although I think you can
charge it with hydrogen to keep it the
same size because it's only expanding
because it's a losing hydrogen yeah yes
but fuel so it expands but you can keep
fueling it I think you can preserve it
sure if we can if we can find uh a
magnitude of hydrogen and transport it
to agree that the sun you absorb
Saturn's uh hydrogen and shoot it with
an electro laser into the Sun the the
complexity of doing that is probably
a similar complexity to being able to
survive Interstellar space
that we are vulnerable is true I think
we're more vulnerable to Media strikes
to meteorologists here's the other thing
nor a link
if you guys have watched altered carbon
have you seen altered carbon at all no
so here what here's what I think Elon
might be thinking right now based on the
technology we have not what we might
achieve he's trying to build
Interstellar travel yeah it's entirely
possible we develop a means of
conveyance much much faster than we have
today and you don't need rocketry it can
be something else
that being said at our current level of
Technology Elon is building Starship
let's say Starship decides to go to
Alpha Centauri or something I don't even
know how how long will it take to get
there a thousand years something like
that it's like 13 light years away so
that's you know at the speed of at
almost the speed of light is 13 years so
so let's humans Thousand Years finally
make it there and then start colonizing
they will need to use quantum
entanglement to communicate between
Centauri and Earth in real time which
they could so you know you mentioned
earlier I think you're you're mentioning
technology is not quite there yet for
but but it's it's it's there enough to
where we've done it we've we've messed
with entangled I think electrons or
something I don't know exactly photons
probably photons maybe and so like you
you energize one and the other one
reacts the same way as if they're
connected in in another dimension so
it's like it looks far apart to us but
actually in the fourth dimension it's
the same thing so that means we can have
one on the planet in office
simplification of the theories like in
in the fourth dimension they're actually
in the same spot dramatic
oversimplification like you know yeah
yeah I'm probably way wrong about it but
it's like a general idea like they're
attached for some reason but so what
happens is if you can vibrate it in
binary then you can transmit data in
real time in real time not even at the
speed of Fast and the speed of light
because it's not actually traveling at
all it's just and then you do data
transfer and then with neural link you
can data transfer your mind from planet
to planet like in Altered carbon so that
may be what they're thinking like how do
humans travel to different planets you
don't you transport your brain the only
thing is if you're a religious person
you're not actually going there you're
like cloning you're copying your brain
so there's so that I've heard Richard
Dawkins talking about this uh and
someone was I've heard you guys talk
about whether or not you can upload your
brain or upload your Consciousness to
the to to a computer and stuff and
personally I don't think that it's
possible I think that you are you I
think that your brain is you
right again I don't think that there I
don't think that it's possible to create
you without your brain I think that the
experience that you have of existence is
intrinsic to your brain so there is no
Ian without Ian's brain so you can't
upload Ian to the computer because Ian's
brain is always inside Ian so you're
even if all of the information in your
brain was uploaded to the computer it's
not going to be your Consciousness
because your Consciousness exists in the
meat in your head do you think that we
could extract the brain stem creature
from a body put it in a vat and then let
it still be the person that seems that
seems possible
like I mean like you know whatever the
the the monster from uh Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles where the brain was in his
stomach or whatever
maybe it's that's well but I just don't
think that human beings exist in absence
of a brain have you guys watched the
peripheral on Amazon so uh yeah it's
really good I'm watching it now but
basically it's also like uh surrogates
or Avatar if we can do quantum
entanglement Communications high speed
data transfer then you could put on a
headset yeah and then pilot a body on
the other planet and go around you also
have you'd be able to see the future
because if you know if I know what you
know before you throw the ball at me I
see it coming
let's read some more we got this from uh
Zach darce he says Tim Jordan Peterson
should stand his ground and not delete
the Tweet also Tim I don't think there's
any moral victory in keeping a tweet up
so I deleted to get my account back why
the flip-flop on principles Tim I'm
pretty sure that I said there's no point
in keeping up the single tweet for
Jordan Peterson and he'd be more
effective just communicating with his
audience abandoning his millions of
followers for one single tweet is
probably less effective in terms of
winning the culture award like I'm
pretty sure that's what I said right I
don't know
or either way then if that wasn't the
case
I don't know my current opinion is if
Jordan Peterson gets locked out for a
single tweet and he can remove it and
gain access to millions of people why
Retreat from the Battleground it's been
my position on everything like Tim why
don't you get off YouTube because
YouTube is Central Battleground it's
where younger people get their content
it's the most popular popular social
media platform so why get off the
battlefield get off when you're forced
off you know so my view on Twitter was
I'm more effective tweeting about how
stupid Twitter is than just keeping up
one tweet from three months ago that no
one remembers anyway yeah and in those
environments if you keep up the fight I
don't really like that metaphor much but
if you stay on the platform uh you may
not find that you actually end up
winning the war like Elon bought the
platform so Jordan if he had stayed on
and deleted that tweet maybe he could
just reinstall the Tweet now so you
could argue that there was a loss a net
loss there by being vacant from the
platform for a year oh uh I'll read one
more decent says [ __ ] brand coffee best
coffee beanies graph Ian dark roast
roast dark rooster okay
graph Ian or Ian's graphene blend for a
dark roast is a really smart idea I
don't want people eating graphene it's
not really crunchy what are you talking
about yeah I know dude yeah let's do it
put like the hexagon right yeah yeah
we'll put like a hexagonal thing and
it'll be Ian's dark roasts uh we'll
we'll have to figure out the right blend
so we'll get some samples and then you
should formulate you know what you think
works and then vanilla dark vanilla
Blend or something well vanilla yeah
dark vanilla vanilla flavoring coffees
so it's Hit or Miss avoid flavoring
coffees you found yeah I'd say what you
want to do is you want to just look at
like Italian French or other dark roast
then figure out what percentage blend
you think works we'll have to get some
Trade Fair coffee I hope hopefully
everything Fair Trade coffee so that
means that slave labor wasn't involved
in producing the coffee beans that's
where that's important to me all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com hang out with us for the
uncensored not so family friendly
portion of the show which should be live
on the website at about 11 pm go go to
timcast.com click join us when you sign
up you are also supporting parallel
economy they handle all of our financial
transactions so you're helping build the
actual parallel economy and help us get
away from certain companies like PayPal
and other censorious financial
institutions you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me at timcast
Phil you want to shout anything out I am
Phil abanti I sing for the metal band
All That Remains uh follow me on Twitter
it is at Phil that remains uh I'm
closing in 100 000. give me a follow
Phil that was great thank you so much
for coming on you are awesome uh my
YouTube channel is youtube.com forward
slash we are change YouTube is showing
no one my video today uh because it's
pretty spicy I talked about artificial
intelligence human harvesting Elon
really interesting topics youtube.com
forward slash we are change I'm going to
be engaging with everyone in the comment
section there right now uh and uh check
it out thanks for having me always a
pleasure Phil great to see you again my
man love it when you come out here
um I'm Ian Crossing follow me at Ian
crossland.net and get through to me on
any of my social networks from there and
I'll see you later
it was a great show great to meet you
Phil uh you can find me everywhere at
Kellen PDL thanks guys yeah
mentioned we're also working on cold
brew uh getting a cold brew blend of our
own the only problem is we have to order
15
000 cans per order so it's like you got
to make a very serious investment if you
want to do your own proprietary cold
brew cans and I do so we've got to
figure it out but I think we can pull it
off and we can cardboard uh a cans
usually have plastic lined with them
um but we'll talk about that later all
right everybody thanks for hanging out
we will see you all over at timcast.com
Phil we'll cry one more time yeah
foreign